أنا أزعم أني إنسان عاقل
عاقل، مو كويس
ما يمكن يا عبدالرحمن لأي عاقل في الدنيا
يشتغل في الصحافة
يبحث عن إساءة لنادي مثل «الهلال»
أي عاقل!
اللي موب عاقل خلّه هذا موضوع ثاني
بديت أشك في عقلك طيب يا بتال
لا، لا يمكن
أنا أقولها قدام كل العالم
والناس كلهم بيشوفون المقابلة دي
لا أبحث عن رضا النصراويين ولا أبحث عن رضا الهلاليين
أنا أبحث عن الرضا المهني
فيه كثير من الصحفيين وجودهم قايم على وجود التعصّب
هو لو كان يقف بين كل الأندية؛ لم يصبح له قيمة
لا يوجد فريق يمثل الوطن إلا المنتخب
الفرق تمثل أنفسها
حتى لو كانت تمثل الوطن؟
حتى لو كانت في بطولة خارجية
حتى لو كانت في كأس العالم؟
حتى لو كانت في كأس العالم
أهلًا، هذا فنجان من ثمانية
وأنا عبدالرحمن أبو مالح
اليوم فيه تطورات وتغيرات ضخمة في مجال الرياضة
خصوصًا كرة القدم في السعودية
إلا أن التطور ما شمل كل شيء
الإعلام؛ واحد منها
حبيت أننا نتكلم عن الصحافة الرياضية
والإعلام الرياضي في السعودية والمنطقة
هل سحب الإعلام الجديد البساط من تحت الإعلام التقليدي؟
هذا كان سؤال الحلقة
رغم إيماني اللي كان مهزوز
وتغيّر مؤخرًا فصار إيمان ثابت بأهمية الإعلام التقليدي
لأسباب عديدة أهمها: الأدوات الصحفية المهنية
اللي يحتاجها المحتوى العربي
واللي يفقد جزء كبير منها في الإعلام الجديد
طبعًا الإعلام الجديد أقل حساسية من النقد
مقابل الإعلام التقليدي الحساس جدًّا
فبكون حذر جدًّا عشان ما حد يزعل أبدًا
اختيار ضيفي كان بعيد عن كل قواعد الحذر
ما انتهت الحلقة إلا وقد نشف دمي
ضيفي العزيز «بتال القوس»
رئيس تحرير صحيفة «الرياضية»
و مقدم برنامج «في المرمى» على قناة «العربية»
قبل أن نبدأ
أطلقنا في ثمانية الموسم الجديد من بودكاست مرتدة
مع الزميلين «عبيدالله العيسي» و«بندر المشرافي»
ومرتدة هو بودكاست رياضي
يهتم بمناقشة أحداث الكرة السعودية
يحاول يعطي تحليل موضوعي لمجرياتها أول بأول
الحلقة الصوتية والمرئية تنشر على قناة إذاعة ثمانية
في نفس الموعد، كل يوم أحد
أما الآن؛ لنبدأ
أنا أشوفك تضيّف ضيوفك قهوة سعودية
زمان
أنا ما أشرب الهيل، الهيل عندي مشاكل معه صحية
أشرب قهوة سوداء على طول
لا، تجيك قهوة سوداء يحبها قلبك
أنت تقول أنك نصراوي صح؟
أنا ما أقول، الناس تقول
بس أنت ما قلت ولم يسألوني؟
لا، قد أنسألت عن الموضوع
قلت: لا، أبد ما أنكر
ما يمكن أن واحد يعمل في الرياضة؛ ما يكون له ميول
صحيح
ما يمكن، إيه
فليش تسوي أن ما عندك ميول؟
تحس أنه ماهي بمهنية؟
لا، ما أسوي
بس أنا أقول...
طبعًا شوف هذه قضية خاسرة جدًّا
أنك تقول للناس فلان بدون ميول
وهو يشتغل في الرياضة
قضية خاسرة أنك تحاول تثبت لهم
فأنت أمام حلين
إما أنك تعمل وتصمت تخلي الموضوع وين ما وصل
أو أنك تتفرغ لهذه القضية أنك تناقشها
إذا تفرغت أنك تناقشها؛ أنت تضيّع وقتك
صح
أبدًا
احنا بدينا صح؟
بدينا الحين
هل اخترت الرياضة لأنك تقول
أن الرياضة هي اللي فيها الصحافة الميدانية الحقيقية
وأن بقية الصحف مجرد علاقات عامة؟
متى قلت أنا هذا الكلام؟
2008 يمكن
عند من؟
في «الاقتصادية» أتوقع
أنا ما أذكر متى قلته، بس هو فعلًا رأيي
أنا ما أتذكر متى قلته الصراحة
لكن هذا واحد من أرائي في زمنٍ ما
على الأقل في الوقت اللي أنا التحقت بالصحافة
ما كان فيه صحافة حقيقية غير الرياضة
2008 ما كان فيه مثلًا أو 2007
وقت اللي طلعت أنت من «شمس»
إيه ما كان فيه
إيه، لأن أغلب الصحف اللي كانت موجودة
أو أغلب التخصصات الصحفية خليني أقول
كانت قائمة على ما يصل لها
من الجهات الرسمية بشكل أو بآخر
وهذه حقيقة، وبعضها ما يزال حتى الآن بنفس الصيغة
الرياضة كانت الوحيدة اللي فيها
مساحة كبيرة من الحركة الميدانية
وكانت فيها مساحة كبيرة من الصحافة الميدانية
اللي تعلّم الصحفي الحقيقة، حقيقة الصحافة
وتعلمه المهنة، تعلمه أدواتها
تعلمه شلون يتقابل مع الطرف الآخر
في القضية أو في الموضوع الصحفي
تعمل مع أطراف متعددة
الرياضة مثلًا كانت كثير عندها مهام خارجية صحفية
مثل؟
البطولات على سبيل المثال
عندها بطولات مختلفة متعددة
تلتقي فيها بشعوب وثقافات وأشياء مختلفة
أكثر من غيرها من الأوساط الصحفية
والسياسة بشكل مستمر
أنا أحب السياسة ترى أكثر من الرياضة
إلى حدٍ كبير ومتابع للسياسة أكثر يمكن في فترةٍ ما
بس السياسة ما كانت مثل الرياضة
يمكن تطور الموضوع الآن بشكل كبير
والصحافة السياسية تطورت إلى أشياء
وتعددت القنوات السياسية صحفيًّا وتلفزيونيًّا
وعلى مستوى الإعلام الجديد
لكن في ذاك الزمن ما كانت بهذا الشكل أبدًا
السياسة وللا الصحافة السياسية؟
السياسة والصحافة السياسية
بتفق معك في جزء
يمكن أقول لك أن السياسة تطورت
على فكرة عبدالرحمن، مش ضروري أننا نتفق
مش ضروري أننا نتفق
أبدًا
بس مو ضروري أننا نأخذ الموضوع دبلوماسي
مش ضروري، يعني احنا...
لا، ودي أنك تقول الصدق والله!
وأنا قاعد أقول الصدق!
بخشى من أيش؟
بقول الصدق، بس أنا لما أقول شيء
وأنت عندك وجهة نظرة أخرى
ترى مو معناته أننا نتفق
إيه بس عادي، بقولك وجهة نظري
تفضل
وشوف إذا تتفق أو لا؟
فنقدر نقول أن السياسة تطورت وأصبحت أكثر حيوية
فيها هذه اللي أنت تقول
الالتقاء مع الشعوب وتغيرات كثيرة وصولات
خلنا نقول التقاء مع أطراف القصة الصحفية
ما كانت موجودة
بس الصحافة إذا ما كانت موجودة آنذاك فهي موجودة الحين
الصحافة السياسية
لا، تطورت أشياء كثيرة فيها
احنا مدري ليش نركز على الصحافة السياسية؟
بجيك الرياضة
إيه، مو بس الرياضة، الصحافة بشكل عام
السياسة نفسها تطورت في أشياء كثيرة
في انفتاحها على الصحافة
وهذا الشيء موجود الآن
يمكن سابقًا ما كان موجود
بالضبط
اتفقنا شوي؟
اتفقنا شوي
بس أنا أبي أعممه
فإذا كانت «الرياضية» أنت أول تقول
أن هي اللي فيها الصحافة الميدانية
وأنواع الصحافة الثانية مجرد علاقة عامة
ترى للاستدلال عبدالرحمن ولا أقطع كلامك
للاستدلال أغلب الصحفيين الكبار
اللي في السياسة خرجوا من الرياضة
الرياضة دربتهم
نتكلم على «عثمان العمير»
رجل عنده إرث صحفي كبير لا شك
بدأ رياضيًّا
نتكلم على «محمد التونسي» صحفي كبير
طبعًا «عبدالرحمن الراشد» الناس تقول
أنه بدأ رياضيًّا، ما بدأ رياضيًّا هو
هو راح غطّى مؤتمر صحفي رياضي
لأنه كان ما في صحافيين فأرسلوه يغطي
بس هو ما بدأ رياضيًّا
هذه نقلًا عنه
بس هل هذا المشهد سعودي بحت؟
هذه من الخصوصية السعودية أن الناس تبدأ في الرياضة
بعدين ينطلقون
أنا ما اشتغلت في دول أخرى صحفيًّا
أطالع صحفهم عن بُعد
بس أكيد فيه أشياء مختلفة
أنت تبغى تجرنا إلى موضوع
هل السبب السياسة وللا السبب الصحافة؟
أكيد كان السبب في فترة من الفترات هي السياسة
أكيد بلا شك
السبب السياسة أنه؟
السياسة انفتاحها على الصحافة
السبب حقيقة
لا، أنا ما أبغى الصدق، أنا أبغى أعرف سبب...
شوف أنا بحط زعم ومن هنا بننطلق
أن الصحافة السعودية متدهورة
ومن هنا أنا بنطلق
إذا أنت تقول: أن الصحافة الرياضية زمان كانت ممتازة
والبقية لها علاقة...
لا، ما قلت ممتازة
فيه فرق بين التقييم وبين وصف الحالة
أبد، أبغى آخذه نصًا، أن الصحافة...
لا، فيه فرق كبير
أنا أتكلم أنك لما تجي تبغى تدرب واحد على الميدان
كانت الصحافة الرياضية أوسع، لا شك
إيه كانت الصحافة الرياضية فيها أدوات التدريب أكثر من غيرها
في الميدان على سبيل المثال
حتى في الرقابة كانت الصحافة الميدانية في تلك الفترة
أفقها أوسع بكثير من بقية الأوساط الصحفية الأخرى في الرقابة
وهذا يعطي ميدان للحركة
ويعطي ميدان لـ (الإبداع) أحيانًا
وهذا يعطي مجال لأشياء أخرى كثيرة
إلى الآن وللا؟
لا
مو الرياضة أعلى
صحيح أن السقف نزل على الجميع
بس الرياضة لا تزال
صحيح هذا الوصف، أنه نزل السقف
ممكن ما نزل بمعنى نزل
ولكن أصبحت العين عليه مفتحة كثير من أول
زمان ممكن تعمل أشياء كثير في الرياضة
ما حد ينتبه لك ترى، ولا واحد جاب خبرك
ممكن تمسك لك بني آدم وتشدّبه تشديب
تعلقه في سيخ شاورما
للأسف الشديد ما كانت حتى أدبيات
بس الآن لا، الآن فيه عين رقابية موجودة
فيه قواعد بشكل أو بآخر
حتى فيه قواعد إجرائية عقابية موجودة
ما كانت موجودة في السابق
أبدًا ما كانت موجودة
ترى أنا لحقت على الفترة هذه اللي أنا قاعد أحكيك فيها
أنا طبعًا اشتغلت صحافة وأنا في الجامعة
فلحقت على جزء كبير منها
بعدين جاء التسلسل الرقابي
اللي بدأ يصعد ويصعد إلى زمننا الحالي
وللا يمكن ما أسميه
ودي أوجد مفردة أخرى غير رقابي أدق وصف
خليني نقول أصبح أمام النظر
في السابق ما كان أمام النظر بصراحة
وين كان؟
القسم الرياضي والصحافة الرياضية
كانت في مكان آخر عن العالم
معقولة؟
صحيح
لدرجة أني أقول لك أن فيه كثير من المقالات
تصدق لو ترجع لها، تقول كيف نشرت في ذاك الزمن
كان فيه زوايا صحفية لا تنتمي للصحافة
زوايا غمز ولمز والأشياء دي
مو موجودة في أي شيء في الصحافة
إلا في الصحافة الرياضية
وتقول شلون تمشي هذه؟
أي فنٍ من فنون الصحافة هذا؟
تسأل نفسك وأنت تقرأ
فنون الصحافة، كلنا نعرفها
الخبر والمقال والتحقيق وإلى آخره
هذا أي فن منها؟
وين تضعها في التصنيف؟
ما تجد لها تصنيف، بس كان موجود
لأنه لم يكن هناك عين فاحصة تراقب هذا المشهد
أو هذا الوسط في تلك الفترة
أتذكر لقائك مثلًا مع الأمير «عبدالله بن مساعد» فين؟
يوم كان رئيس «الهلال»
أو يوم كان موجود أيام الأمير «عبدالله بن مساعد»
والله ما أعرف كان رئيس...
بس إذا تتذكر، تتذكر حدتك فيه
غير الرياضة لا يمكن بهذه الحدة أنك تكون مع أي مسؤول، صح؟
صحيح
حتى لو كانت قصدي بالمهنية
رغم وجود المهنية إلا أنه حاد
وهذه الحدية لا تنطبق في أي وسط ثاني
يمكن يكون وصفك دقيق
عبدالله زعل مني وهو صديقي الغالي جدًّا
وزعل ذيك الفترة
بس أننا تناقشنا وصلنا إلى حلول
خلنا نقول وصلنا إلى حلول
وهو غالي علي جدًّا أبو عبدالرحمن
وهو من أكثر الناس اللي يتفهمون
حتى أدوار الصحافة الرياضية
طيب ودي أنك تصف لي مشهد الصحافة
مو بالرياضة أو الصحافة الرياضية
الصحافة في السعودية كيف تجدها اليوم؟
الرياضية؟
لا، أنا ودي الصحافة إجمالًا
وإذا تبغى بعدين نزل الرياضة
احنا نتكلم عن الصحافة الحين بكل أنواعها
التلفزيونية والورقية والإعلام الإلكتروني والإعلام الجديد
هي تمر في فترة نشاط هائل
نشاط هائل؟
نشاط هائل الحقيقة
أنا أعتقد أنها فترة نشاط تفتقد للكثير من القواعد الصحفية المهمة
لكن النشاط نشاط موجود هائل جدًّا
فيه قفز من المعسكر الثاني
اللي هو معسكر الإعلام الناشطين
أنا سمعت محاضرة والله نسيت اسمها
عشان بس نقول أنه هو صاحب المصطلح إعلام الناشطين
ناسي والله، واحد في وحدة من المعاهد الصحفية
سماهم إعلام الناشطين وإعلام التقليديين
من يقصد بالناشطين؟
إعلام الناشطين هو الإعلام الجديد
هو إعلام لا يمكن بأي حال من الأحوال
أن نقول أنه غير موجود
هو موجود، هل هو إعلام؟
فيها مو قولان، لا أكثر من قول
ولكن هل هو موجود؟ أكيد أنه موجود
هل هو إعلام يتسم أو يتصف
بالقواعد المهنية الصحفية الحقيقية؟
لا أبدًا، هذا غير موجود
هل هو إعلام انكشف في مرحلة من المراحل؟ نعم
خلينا نتخيل مثلًا الدول والحكومات والمجتمعات
متى عادت إلى الإعلام التقليدي؟
في الثلاث السنوات الأخيرة
في فترة كورونا مثلًا
ليش رجعوا الناس إلى الإعلام التقليدي؟
عدم ثقة في إعلام الناشطين
لأن إعلام الناشطين أصبح يروّج أشياء
حتى بيجيك واحد يتكلم، طيب هذا مين اللي يتكلم؟
ما أدري
هذا مين؟
فالإعلام التقليدي دائمًا هو مؤصل أكثر
هو صاحب مصداقية أعلى
وهو عنده قواعده المهنية الراسخة
هو ما يكسر القواعد
ما عنده القدرة أن يكسر القواعد الصحفية الحقيقية
بس إعلام النشيطين أساسًا ماهي موجودة عنده
هذا شيء من المشهد اللي موجود الآن
في الصحافة السعودية بشكل عام
الكلام طويل عبدالرحمن في موضوع الصحافة
ولكن هذا جزء من الوصف
للحالة اللي أنا أعتقد أنها هي الأكثر حديث
الأكثر اجتذابًا للتحليل والنقد في هذا الفترة
اللي هو ما بين إعلام الجديد والإعلام القديم
إذا بناخذ الإعلام القديم
أنك تقول هذا في فترة توهج
وتشوف مبنى «الجزيرة» جالس يؤجر إلى عيادة!
أنا ما قلت فترة توهج، هذه عبارتك أنت
أنا أعدت الصياغة
لا، عِد الصياغة لنفسك
فيه فرق بين أنك تعيد الصياغة وأنك تغيّرها
لا، أنا أقول أنها فترة نشاط
احنا نتكلم عن فترة نشاط
نتكلم الآن الشركة السعودية «إس آر إم جي»
نشطة جدًّا على مستويات عالية
قاعدة تفتح قنوات جديدة، صح وللا لا؟
هذا نشاط وللا ماهو بنشاط؟
نشاط
قاعدة تفتح منصات جديدة
صحيح
مختلفة، مش صحيفة وللا...
لا، هذا نشاط عالي
«إم بي سي» أيضًا عندها نفس النشاط
«إم بي سي» عندها منصات جديدة
نتكلم على «شاهد» نتكلم على قنواتها الجديدة اللي قاعدة تسويها
نتكلم عن احتواء واحتضان القنوات الجديدة
مثل «الثقافية» في الفترة الأخيرة
هذا نشاط وللا ماهو بنشاط؟
نشاط
تقييم هذا النشاط موضوع آخر
أنت تكلمت في جزئية عن صحيفة «الجزيرة»
أنها قاعدة تأجر مبناها
هذا جزء من الإعلام
«الجزيرة» مجرد صحيفة ورقية
وتحولت إلى صحيفة ورقية بشكل محدود
دائمًا ما أحب أتكلم عن الزملاء
لأن أنا جزء من الموضوع
فمش مناسب أني أتكلم عنه
ولكن احنا تأخرنا كثير في الانتقال للمرحلة ما بعد الورقي
الصحافة السعودية تأخرت كثير
بما فيهم الشركة السعودية اللي جزء منها
تأخرت في فترة من الفترات بشكل كبير
وهذه التأخير قاعدة تدفع ثمنه
الآن هي تحاول أن تختصر الخطوات التي فاتتها
وفيه أحد ينجح
وفيه أحد من الصعب جدًّا أن يعوّض ما فات
فيه برضه حوار 2008 قلته مكتوب، كنت تقول
أن القارئ لا بد أن يرفض ما جرت به العادة في الصحافة
والصحف يجب أن تتجرأ وتتجرأ
حتى لا يتجرأ القارئ على شتمها
طيب هذا وين كان؟
ما شاء الله كنت أقول كلام جميل في 2008
هذا في «العربية»
والله كنت تقول كلام
فكان سؤالي هل أنت باقي بتال 2008؟
ما زلت
ما زلت؟
وما زلت أدفع ثمن
أي ثمن اللي دفعته؟
فيه أثمان كثير يا عبدالرحمن تمر فيك وأنت...
بس ما تحس أن القارئ له خمسة عشر سنة رافض
رافض ماذا؟
الصحف
ولا شيء تغيّر
أيش خلاك تقول كذا؟
رافض لأيش بالضبط؟
هل تعتقد أن اليوم «الرياضية» وأنت رئيسها
«العربية» وأنت تقدم فيها برنامجك «في المرمى»
نفس الوهج اللي كانت فيها في 2008؟
أكيد لا
وبسحب هذا الوصف على بقية الصحف
شوف بقولك شيء
أول شيء تعددت المنصات هذا سبب
والسبب الثاني احنا في زمن سرعة هائلة
الناس تبحث عن السرعة أكثر مما تبحث عن...
أنا بقول لك تحليلي الخاص
الناس لم تعد تضبط ساعاتها على برنامج تلفزيوني
ولكن الناس من وين تشوفك الآن؟
إذا أنت سمّعت؛ ممكن تروح تشوفك على منصات أخرى
أنا أقول لك الآن، على سبيل المثال «في المرمى»
يمكن لا يوجد أحد، لا يوجد بنفس العدد السابق
اللي الساعة 1:00 جات حط «العربية» بشوف «في المرمى»
يمكن لا
تراني أقول (يمكن) هذه بين قوسين
لأنها يمكن تقول 60-40، 70-30، 50-50
الله أعلم كم تكون النسبة
لكن هو في وقت فراغه
بكرة يدخل على قناة البرنامج في يوتيوب
يدخل على «شاهد» يعيد الحلقة
اللي ما يعجبه يقدم بالحلقة، ويشوف اللي يعجبه
وهذا أصبح موجود في زماننا
نرجع ونقول هل الصحافة الورقية انتهت؟
نرجع نقول هل التلفزيون انتهى؟
أجل المواد اللي تنشر على وسائل التواصل من وين جاية؟
من وين؟
هي جاية من الصحافة الورقية أو جاية من التلفزيون
بس هل أحد يتفرجها في نفس الوقت؟
لا، أتكلم الحين 70-80
و ترى سبعين أنا مرة جاي عليهم
ترى 80% من المواد اللي تقدم في تويتر
عطني مادة تقدم في تويتر ليس لها سند إعلامي واضح
ما في
20% عشان بعد نكون موضوعيين
20% خلنا نقول، ما في
20% منهم: هذا مفكر
ناقد يقدم نقده من خلال تويتر فقط كمنصة مثلًا
من خلال إكس
أو طرف في قضية اختار أن يعلق عن طريق هذه المنصة
لكن بقية الأشياء الناس ينقلونها عن الإعلام
ما يزالون ينقلونها على الإعلام التقليدية
ما يزالون إلى الآن
مؤمن باللي تقوله؟
إيه
والله؟ ما تشوف مثلًا أخبار الانتقالات عني أتوقع
كلنا ناخذها من هذا الإيطالي أيش اسمه؟
لا مو بصحيح، مو كلنا
شوف كم إذا نزّل خبر
كم عدد التفاعل معه من كل العالم
كثير من الأخبار اللي نزلها هو
نزلتها «الرياضية» قبله
والله؟
إيه، صحيح
نقدر نسوي رصد
لا، مو مشكلة بس أبغاك
نقدر نسوي رصد ترى عبدالرحمن
أبد والله، أنا باخذ كلامك على أنه صحيح
ما عندي مشكلة
بس أنت شايف التفاعل اللي يحظى به؟
صحيح شايف التفاعل
وهو فرد، تقدر تاخذ في التحليل
خلني أقول لك يا عبدالرحمن مرة أنا كنت في مجلس
«الرياضية» عندها حساب اسمه «عاجل»
«عاجل الرياضية» من أهم حساباتها
اللي تنقل بس عواجل ما تنقل مواد
فأنا كنت أراسل الزملاء على خبر عاجل وهم يرسلون لي
نشيّك على أنه متى يصدر
أنا انبسطت مرة، كنت سعيد جدًّا
لما في المجلس يمكن ستة كانوا أو خمسة
احنا كنا يمكن عشرة تقريبًا
كلهم جاهم تنبيه على رسالة «عاجل الرياضية»
هما لما يحطون تنبيه «عاجل الرياضية»
الحقيقة كنت سعيد
كان فيه واحد من الاجتماعات أيضًا في نفس الوقت
من مسؤولين جهة الرياضية
نفس الشيء شفته قدامي، هذا ممتاز
تبي تقولي يا عبدالرحمن أن فيه اندفاع
بوسائل الإعلام الجديد بما فيهم «فابريزيو» مثلًا أو غيره
هذا صحيح موجود
الجمهور دائمًا يبحث عن الجديد
جمهور الرياضة على فكرة لما تقول له
عندنا ست صفقات السنة دي وقعنا
وخلصوا الست صفقات معاد فيه أصلًا خانة يسجل فيها
يقول: ما في صفقة جديدة؟
هم كذا دائمًا يبحثون عن أشياء
لكن ما في شك بأن الإعلام الجديد متابع أكثر من القديم
وأنا أعتقد أن 80% من مادته ما زالت هي من الإعلام التقليدي
بس أنا بقول لك إذا الأخبار صارت تتنوع
وممكن الحين حتى فيه جزء آخر
اللي هو أصبح المصدر نفسه؛ قادر على نقلها
فما عاد الأندية بحاجة إلى «الرياضية» أو أي قناة ثانية
يستطيع أن ينشرها في *صفحته
هي المنافسة على الخبر لم تعد هي المضمار الأول
ممتاز، فقدت الصحف التقليدية الخبر
لا ما فقدته 100%
ولكن لم تعد هي المضمار الأول
ممتاز والتحليل؟
التحليل ما يزال موجود وأقل من السابق
إذا جينا نبغى نتكلم عن ما فقدته
هي فقدت الكثير لا شك
أيش بقي؟
أنت تشوف الأشياء المؤسسات...
نقفلها؟
لا، لا
طيب؟
مثلًا إذا ناخذ الأشياء الصعبة اللي محد يقدر يسويها
مثلًا الوثائقيات الرياضية اللي تبغى تاخذ...
التحقيقات الصحفية
إيه، موجودة
أنا أتذكر، فيه بعض الأشياء اللي حاضرة
«في المرمى» أتذكّر لك بعض الأشياء
بس قليلة
وهذه لا يستطيع عليها اللي أنت سميته الإعلام الناشط؟
إعلام الناشطين، مو أنا سميته بس عجبني المصطلح
وأُيّده، وأقف خلفه
ما في مشكلة
بس هذولا ما يقدرون عليها
أين الإعلام التقليدي أو المؤسساتي من هذه الأشياء؟
ما في شك، أنا قلت قبل شوي
فيه مضامير كثيرة لم تصبح أنت الأول فيها
وأصبح التنافس فيها على أشده
لكن أنت لا تأخذ الجزئيات بس وتبني عليها قصة كاملة
أنا تكلمت بشكل عام ترى
أكيد بلا شك، الخبر لم يعد السباق فيه
لم يعد هو البطولة الأولى في المضمار
لكن فيه جوانب كثيرة ما تزال الفنون موجودة في الصحافة
مثل؟ عطني الأشياء اللي ما تزال هي الصحافة التقليدية
أو صحافة الرسمية أو الصحافة القديمة
الإعلام التقليدي ككل
اللي ما يزال...
الثقة
الثقة؟
الثقة أكثر موجودة
أعتقد أن ثقة الإعلام الجديد التقليدي
ما تزال موجودة أكثر وأكثر
لدى المؤسسات الرسمية، الحكومات
لدى المجتمع بشكل أو بآخر
أعتقد أن المهارات الصحفية الحقيقية
ما تزال موجودة أكثر في الإعلام هذا
القواعد المهنية ما تزال موجودة أكثر
الإعلام الجديد بشكل أو بآخر
هو أول شيء خلنا نعترف أننا نسميه إعلام
فيه شكوك حول هذا الموضوع
لكن بالأخير هو كيان موجود
ما تقدري تلغيه
نقدر نقول أن هو إعلام بس مو بصحافة؟
أيش الفرق؟
إذا افترضنا أن الإعلام هو أي أحد يكون إعلامي عادي
كيف؟
بمجرد أنك تقدر تصل للناس
لكن الصحافة يجب أن تحافظ على مهنية معينة
شوف يا عبدالرحمن فيه أصلًا
يبدو أنك تحب تقاطع حتى لو كنت ضيف
لا، بس أحب أستوضح
أستوضحك بس لأني لاحظت أنك تأخذ جزئيات
فحبيت أستوضحك
أبدًا لا أقصد
لا، هو أصلًا إذا رجعنا للتعريفات احنا بندخل في بحر عميق
في الإعلام عمومًا فيه خلاف كبير على التعريفات
حتى أكاديميًّا
فيه خلاف على تعريف الموضوعية
فيه خلاف على تعريف الحيادية
الموضوعية البحثية هي غير الموضوعية الإعلامية
الحيادية السياسية غير الحيادية الإعلامية
فيه كثير من التعريفات في الإعلام
فيه جدليات حوالها
وفيه تعريفات أحيانًا تكون متناقضة
أحد يقول لك: الحيادية موقف
واللي يقول لك: لا الحيادية هي كذا
واللي يقول لك: الموضوعية هي إجراءات وقواعد
واحد يقول لك: لا، الموضوعية هي ضد الذاتية
التعريفات هذه مختلفة
إذا جينا لموضوع كما تقول لي الإعلام
أيش كنت تقول؟
الإعلام أنه أي واحد يعلم الناس فهو صار إعلامي؟
هذا التعريف البسيط للإعلام
لكن أيضًا فيه ناس يقولوا لك
أي أحد يشتغل بالإعلام هو إعلامي، كيف؟
إذا أنت في مؤسسة، مثل مؤسستكم إعلامية
القهوجي اللي عندك إعلامي، كذا
كيف؟
أنا ضربت المثل بالقهوجي
بس كأصغر أفراد هذه مؤسسة الإعلامية
اللي يجي يقول الإعلامي يشتغل في وسائل الإعلام في الأرشيف
إعلامي!
بينما فيه ناس آخرين يقول لك
الفرق بين الإعلامي والصحفي
الإعلامي هو الذي اشتغل في كل من المنصات الإعلامية
برضه هذا تعريف مقبول، صح وللا لا؟
صح
طيب أيش ناخذ منهم، هذا وللا هذا؟
هل ناخذ تعريف...
إذن أرجع وأقول لك من البداية
أن فيه كثير من الجدليات حول المفاهيم والتعريفات في الإعلام
أبرزها الإعلام، أبرزها من هو الإعلامي؟
أيش تعريف بتال للإعلامي؟
والله شوف، أنا لا ألغي التعريف اللي يقول
أي أحد يشتغل في جهة إعلامية فهو إعلامي
لا ألغيه
ولكن أنا أميل إلى الإعلامي هو اللي يشتغل في المنصات الإعلامية المتعددة
أنا أميل بشكل أكثر من غيره
والصحفي طبعًا موضوع ثاني
إيه، فالصحفي يختلف عن الإعلامي
ليس كل إعلامي صحفي
طبعًا أنا قلت لك أني أميل له
مو معنى هذا الكلام حبيبنا
أن أنا أرى هذا التعريف القاطع
لأن الجدليات نسبية في هذا الموضوع
بس أنا أميل له لأن فيه تعريف أقرب بالنسبة لي
الصحفي هو ممارس الصحافة بفنونها
بنجي لأيش تعريف الصحافة؟
الصحفي خلينا نقول مارس الصحافة بأدواتها الكتابية
الصحافة بأدواتها الميدانية، الصحافة بأدواتها الإدارية
هذا الصحفي
طيب قبل شوي أنت ذكرت الحياد والموضوعية والانحياز
هل من المهنية أن الواحد يعلن عن ميوله
مثلًا في الرياضة أو حتى انحيازه؟
ما تحتاج تعلنها في الوسط الرياضي
إيه، بتعلن؟
لا، ما تحتاج تعلنها
لأن في الوسط الرياضي ما يخلون شيء ما يعرفونه
أنا ما أميل للإعلان، ما أميل أبدًا
ليش؟
شوفهم بالأخير هما بيقولوا لك
وبيجيبون ترى تاريخ من أيام ولاتك إلى اليوم
أنت أيش سويت في الوسط الرياضي
ما شاء لله عليهم في هذه الأمور
ولكن أنا ما أميل له
لأن ما يهم أيش ميولك، ما يهم أبدًا
المهم أنك ماذا تفعل في الصحافة
«أحمد الفهيد» كان قال قبل: أنا مع الصحافة المنحازة
تتفق معه؟
منحازة؟
إيه، يقول لو طلبت مني أؤسس صحيفة
رياضية؟
رياضية
يجب أن أعلن ميولي، وأن أنحاز إلى فريق معين
لا، فرق عبدالرحمن بينه
حتى فرق بين إعلان الميول وبين صحافة منحازة
الصحافة المنحازة متخذة موقف
الصحافة المنحازة ضد الحياد تمامًا
لا، أنا ماني مع الصحافة
شوف «أحمد» واحد هو من أهم الصحفيين
يمكن «أحمد» قصده أن من الصعوبة تطبيقها
أنا أفهمه كذا، أنا أفهمه
لكن سالفة أن هي الصح؛ لا ما أتفق معها
ما أتفق أن احنا نؤسس صحافة منحازة
ما أتفق أبدًا
إذا يقول لك: الصحافة هدفها تجاري وهي مشروع تجاري
يجب أن أعلن ميولي، لأن التجارة ما تجي أني أكون عادي بين الجميع
وأن اللي بكسبه بلعب به
ما أعتقد
والله؟
لا، ما أعتقد
مثلًا فيه «ماركا» الأسبانية
تعلن ميولها لـ «ريال مدريد» وناجحة بكل المقاييس
ما تعلن، الناس يعلنون
تتوقع ما تعلن؟
لا، ما تعلن
لا يا عبدالرحمن ما تعلن
التقارير أيش تقول؟
اللي تنقل عن «ماركا» مثلًا وللا عن «آس» تقول
صحافة «ماركا» القريبة من «ريال مدريد»
هذا وصف الصحافة الأخرى، بس هي ما تصف نفسها
أنا لما أجي مثلًا أقول فلان الفلان
الباحث في شؤون العلاقات السعودية البريطانية، مثلًا
هذا وصف
صحيح
إيه، فهم الناس تصفها
وسائل الإعلام الأخرى تصفها
تقولك أن صحيفة «آس»
وللا صحيفة الـ«ماركا» القريبة من «ريال مدريد»
وهذه «الكتالونية» القريبة من «برشلونة» وهذا وصف
بس هم ما يعلنون
ما في مشكلة ما يعلنون، بس تقدر...
أنت شوف الـ«ماركا» طيب لما يفوز «برشلونة» على «ريال مدريد»
شوف عنوانهم، مدريدي؟
بس طيب ناخذ مثال على زماننا
الصراحة أنا من زمان ما أتابع صحيفة «الجزيرة»
كان صحيفة «الجزيرة» برضه توصف بأنها هلالية، صح؟
بس «الجزيرة» ما يقولون أنهم هلاليين
ما يقولون، بس واضحة
نتفق أنا وأنت أنهم هلاليين؟
لا، هم ما يقولون
شوف عندهم وعندهم
لا يعني أن هم مو هلاليين
أنا دائمًا أقول لك لأني أشتغل في نفس المجال
ما ودي أطلق آراء قاطعة تجاه الزملاء
لو سألتي عن نفسي بجاوب، لكن من ناحية الزملاء
ما ودي أطلق أراء قاطعة تجاههم
لأن هذا حق الزمالة علي
بس بقول آرائي، هذا لا يمنع من قول الآراء
الناس كانوا يوصفون «الجزيرة» و«الرياض» حتى
بأنهم صحفية الوسطى الهلالية
هذا صحيح كانوا يوصفونهم
هل كانت «الرياض» و«الجزيرة» تقول عنهم؟
هذا اللي كنا نقوله قبل شوي
ما في مشكلة
بس إذا أنا بسويها ما بعلن
مثلًا إذا افترضت أني بمشي مع مدرسة «أحمد»
إذا أنا ببنيها أن أنا أبغى أخدم
وأبغى أخلي جمهور «الهلال» يتابعني بالدرجة الأولى
أنت سويت خط وسطي الآن، بين كلام «أحمد» وبين كلامي
تقول ماني معلن، بس بسوّيها
هذا موضوع ثاني
وتجد أنه منطقي
أنا حقيقة ما أميل لها
ما تميل لها؟
لا
ليش؟
الصحافة هي الصحافة عبدالرحمن
الصحافة هي الصحافة الحقيقية اللي يمكن تقدم مادة أو مهنة
بغض النظر عن طرفها
أنت يجب أن تحترمني لما أقدمه
لا تحترمني لأني أتفق معك في نفس اللون
إذا كنت بتحترمني عشان بتفق معك في نفس اللون
أنت يوم من الأيام بتختلف معي لمجرد أننا اختلفنا
القناعة ماهي قناعة راسخة بينك وبينك
ماهي قاعدة صلبة اللي نقف أنا وإياك عليها
وطبيعي أن حتى الهلاليين اثنين يختلفون على واحد
يختلفون على لاعب وعلى رئيس وعلى مدرب
إذن قاعدتنا ماهي بصلبة
أنا دائمًا أنحاز إلى الصحافة
ما أنحاز إلى الكيانات ولا أنحاز إلى الألوان
ترى من يسمع كلامنا ذا، يقول إيه صدقتك
ليش؟ نفس الكلام اللي قلته لك قبل شوي
مثلًا أنت سواءً أعلنت أو ما أعلنت
بس يُعرف عنك أنك نصراوي
ومع ذلك يبان في كثير من التقارير
أنك تشد على الهلاليين واجد
والنصراويين أيضًا
والله؟
إيه، بس يمكن صوت النصراوي ما يصل عندك كويس
يمكن
أو يمكن ما في جمهور كفاية عشان يوصله إلى عندي
برضه منطقي، يمكن عندك أنت ما فيه جمهور كفاية للنصر
أو عندك جمهور «الهلال» أكثر
كله وارد
لا، تعرف هذه القصة دائمًا أزلية
بيني أنا وبين النصراويين والهلاليين
الهلاليين هم يعتقدون أنه...
أنا أزعم أني إنسان عاقل
عاقل، مو كويس
ما يمكن يا عبدالرحمن لأي عاقل في الدنيا
يشتغل في الصحافة
يبحث عن إساءة لنادي مثل  «الهلال» أو الإضرار بالهلال
أي عاقل
اللي مو بعاقل؛ هذا خله، موضوع ثاني
والله بديت أشك في عقلك يا بتال
لا يمكن واحد يبحث عن إضرار بـ«الهلال» لا يمكن
ليه؟ عشان يخسر الجمهور قصدك؟
ولا «النصر» قاعد أقول لك ولا «الاتحاد»
ولا «الأهلي» ولا «الشباب» ما يمكن
لا، أنت مو بهدف أنك تبحث عن ضرر
أنت تبي تشتغل عشان تضرر بالناس؟
لا
لكن خليني أقول لك شيء
أن القضايا أحيانًا هي تكون حقيقتها مضرة
بعبدالرحمن وللا ببتال، وللا بزميلنا وللا بصديقنا
هي حقيقتها مضرة فيك
فأنا أيش أسوي طيب؟
لا بد تنشرها، هذه صحافة
بالأخير هذه صحافة
صحيح
بس ردة تفعل اتجاهها؛ أنا عارف أنك بتزعل
بس يا أخوي والله الشكوى لله، هذه صحافة
أنا عارف أنك بتتهمني
بس الشكوى لله، أنت تذهب إلى الذاتية وتترك الموضوعية
طيب هل بالإمكان أني أعدّل الناس في هذا الموقف؟
أبدًا أنا في الوسط الرياضي
واحمد ربك أنك ما تشتغل فيه
أتعامل مع ناس علاقتهم بكياناتهم
حب، قلب، عاطفية، رباط عاطفي مو بعقلي
الرباط أبدًا ما يكون بالعقل بين النادي ومشجعه
ومراية الحب عمياء وأنت عارف
هو يرى ناديه أفضل شيء
هو لما تجي تقول له
اللاعب الفلاني ترى صرّح ضد فريقك
يقول: ما يخسئ إلا هو
لا، نادينا ملائكة وأنبياء وصالحين وشهداء
فمن الصعوبة أصلًا أنك تقنع الناس بهذا الشيء
إذن هل تدخل في هذه المعركة؟ وللا تشتغل شغلك؟
تشتغل شغلك
طيب؟
بس دقيقة يا بتال، والله
قل لي اللي في خاطرك، أنا حاس في خاطرك
شوف أنا هلالي
أدري أنك هلالي
ما عندك مشكلة
لا، معي؟ بالعكس أيش المشكلة؟
بيتنا فيه هلاليين وأصدقائي هلاليين
على فكرة، أنا في استراحة اللي في الرياض
سبعة نصراويين وسبعة هلاليين، أظن والله العدد كذا
بس أنه حول بعض ما في مشكلة
وعلى فكرة، ترانا مع بعض تدري من متى؟
من سادسة ابتدائي إلى اليوم
إيه بلا شك
إيه، احنا ليش نحاول نفصل ونحول الموضوع إلى عقيدة؟
الناس تختلف في العقائد بس، وهذه حقيقة
حتى حد الدعوة للخلاف في العقيدة
معاد أصبح موجود
فما بالك بالكرة؟
لا، بس اللي كنت بقوله، وبنجي للتعصب
كنت بقول أنه يبان أنك أنت...
ماشي، عطني أدلة
يا حبيبي، بس يبان أنك تشد على الهلاليين
مو أنت مسوي بحث كويس في الحلقة؟
لا
ليش أجل مستضيفني بس كذا نسولف؟
نسولف
أجل لا تقول أسئلة مثل كذا إذا تسولف
خل نسولف في أشياء عامة
لا، بس دقيقة
تتذكر خلافك مع «سامي»؟
إيه
أيش كان خلافي مع «سامي»؟
لا تقول عناوين
لا، طيب السنتر يوم استقعدت له
لا، والله عبدالرحمن وترى «سامي» يعرف ذا الموضوع زين
والله أني سألت «سامي» سؤال كرمزية
والله يعلم
والله؟
شوف خليني أقول لك شيء
احنا كنا مقبلين على كأس العالم
ركز معي، كنت أقول «سامي»
أيش كان شعورك وأنت تسنتر* أمام ألمانيا ثمانية مرات؟
أنا والله في ذيك اللحظة، أقسم بالله
ولا هو مفروض أقسم في لقاء صحفي
لأن كتر الحلف مو بزين
فكنت قصدي الرمزية، رمزيتك أنت ككابتن
هل كنتم تشعرون بألمنا احنا كسعوديين بالخسارة القاسية هذه؟
يمكن الناس ما فهمت
ترى أنا ألتقيت «سامي» في ذلك الفترة
هو كان في دبي وقلتها له
قلت: أنت نفسك ما فهمتني
أنت رحت للجانب السطحي من السؤال
أنا كان قصدي أن رمزيتك أنت ككابتن
الرمزية العالية اللي هي تعطيك الأعلى عن اللعيبة الباقين
لما فعلت هذا الفعل
هل كنت تشعر بنا في السعودية
ونحن نتلقى هذه الخسارة الثمانية
اللي كانت ما ورينا وجيهنا الناس في الكرة بعدها بفترات طويلة
والله كان هذا قصدي، شوف أقسم بالله
لكن ما فهمني هو
ويمكن لأن هو ما فهمني
إجابته كبّرت السالفة، صارت فيها ضديّة أو ندّيّة
و«سامي» ترى ما في بيني وبين خلاف شخصي
على  فكرة احنا أصدقاء الآن
ممتاز
بعد معارك عديدة، ونشوف بعض في دبي أكثر مو في الرياض
وأستمتع بسواليفه وما نرجع للماضي ترى
لا، أنا بقولك مو عشان أنها في وجهك
بس أنا أدري أنك تشجع فريق لا أشجعه
لا يشجع؟
لا أشجعه
يشجع وانتبه لبعض الناس، لكن أنا ما أشجعه
لكني أدري أن مهنيتك عالية
شكرًا
والله جد
ورغم أني أذكر مثلًا تقريرك يوم جاب «الهلال»
أيش البطولة هذيك؟ القرن؟
ما كانت البطولة القرن؟
أيش اسمها؟ الجائزة
الجائزة، تمام
ورحت ولقيته في شقة ماهي موجودة
ترى كان رائع بالنسبة لي
الحمد لله
وأنا هلالي، فما عندي مشكلة
وأنا أتفق على أنها
أنت هلالي هلالي؟
هلالي هلالي
تشوف مباراة «الهلال»؟
أشوفهم بس
أشك والله يا عبدالرحمن
ليه؟ شوف كيف يشوف!
شفت يا بتال أنت كيف؟
لا، أشك أن عندك وقت تشوف كرة
أنا أحس الهلاليين يزعلون منك
لأنك حاط حيلك عليهم
بقوتك، ما أقول أنها بأساليب غير مهنية
الحمد لله
لا، بكل مهنية
بس أنك ما تسويها مع الفرق الثانية
لا
والسلام عليكم ورحمة الله
لا والله يا عبدالرحمن
تعرف أنت لأنك هلالي عايش في إطار الهلاليين
في محيط الهلاليين يحق لك تقول ذا الكلام
وترى طبيعي لو أنا معكم بقوله
لأنك ما تسمع وجهة النظر الأخرى
ما تدري أيش يقولون وجهة النظر الأخرى
أنا في موسم واحد
النصراويين هاشتاقات وسب وشتم وكل شيء
ترى على فكرة لما أقول نصراويين سب
كل ترى الجمهور اللي عندنا كذا
ترى كلهم يتشابهون، كلهم مثل بعض
ما في أحد فرق عن الثاني، فروق بسيطة بس
الاتحاديين نفس الشيء
الأهلاويين نفس الشيء
يا أخي الأهلاويين يرون أني واحد من أسباب الهبوط، ما أدري ليش؟
أنا ما لي دخل
عشاني أعرف «ماجد النفيعي»
إيه، و«ماجد النفيعي» طبعًا صديق وعزيز وكل شيء
بس ترى ما عرفته إلا ما صار رئيس، ما أعرفه قبل
ما عرفته إلا لما صار رئيس النادي
الاتحاديين نفس الشيء
هو كل جمهور الأندية كذا
بس أنت عايش في محيط الهلاليين لأنك هلالي وتسمع
ويمكن للهلال موسيقى خاصة في إذنك
وهذا طبيعي عند كل مشجع
فتسمعها من هذا الجانب
أيضًا جانب آخر
خلنا نتكلم على الشكاوي اللي توصل لرؤسائي أنا سواءً في «العربية»
توصل من الهلاليين أكثر أنا أشوف
ومن النصراويين؛ يمكن يحنون علي
ليه؟
يقولون: بالأخير يشفع له ، لكن والله يقولون
أنا بجيب حسابي في تويتر وخل نسوي رصد معك أنا وياك
ونشوف الهلاليين والنصراويين أيش يقولون
نفس الشيء
بس ليش تقول الهلاليين تجي أكثر؟
لأنهم يزعلون أكثر؟ وللا لأنك تشد عليهم أكثر؟
وللا لأن النصراويين يتعاطفون معك؟
الهلاليين أقوى
الهلاليين أقوى؟
السؤال الثاني
هل تشوف -لأن أنت اللي يصلك الهجوم- كل الأندية
يجيك الهجوم منهم بالتساوي؟
بالتساوي ككمية، بس كفاعلية؛ لا الصراحة
بتخلي الشكاوي تزيد أنت بعد المقابلة
لا، والله حاولت أني أفهمك أكثر بس
طيب التعصب موجود
على فكرة يمكن تراجع عبدالرحمن هذه الأشياء
والله جد بغض النظر عن المقابلة
بس عشان الاستيضاح الفردي الشخصي
راجعها وشوف، كلهم ترى مع الجميع
ترى على فكرة أنا ما أقدر أرتمي في معسكر
عشان معسكر الثاني يرفضني
ما يمكن أني أروح أرتمي في معسكر النصراويين
أنا أقولها قدام كل العالم
والناس كلهم بيشوفون المقابلة دي
لا أبحث عن رضا النصراويين
ولا أبحث عن رضا الهلاليين
أنا أبحث عن الرضا المهني
نحترم كل الناس
وأرجع وأقول لك من الغباء المهني
أنك تستهدف نادي مثل «الهلال»
أو نادي مثل «النصر» أو جمهورهم
هذا غباء مهني كبير
لكن هذا لا يمنع بأنك تمارس مهنتك كما يجب
مثل ما قلت لك علاقة الحب اللي قبل شوي أشرحها لك
اللي هي دائمًا مسيطرة في العلاقة
بين النادي وجمهوره ورغباته وتوجهاته وإلى آخره
مش لحظات الحب المجنونة هذه اللي الناس تحكم عليها
لك أن تتخيل أن أنا أتعامل مع لحظات الجنون لدى العقلاء أيضًا
أوه!
هذا من أصعب الأشياء
فيه صديق مشترك بيني أنا وأنت
فكنت مرة أقول له في لحظة من اللحظات
يمكن المعنويات نازلة كذا
قلت له: أنا خلاص بوقف
قال لي: ليش؟
قلت له: يا أخي عندي فكرة كذا وكذا وكذا
قلت له الفكرة اللي في رأسي
قال لي: ليه
قلت له: يا أخي ملّيت من ذا الجو
مهما سويت؛ أنت صحافة وكذا
ومهما حاولت أنك تكون
ردة الفعل أنك أنت فلان الفلاني وبس؛ ما تحكم عليك
قال لي: لا، فيه ناس عقلاء، وفيه ناس كذا وكذا إلى آخره
آخر شيء تدري أيش قال لي اللي قاعد ينصحني؟
قال: تصدقي لو أشتغل مهنتك كان يمديني انتحرت!
وهو واحد من كبار الصحفيين
مشكلة والله
وهذا لا يحدث إلا في الرياضة، انتقال العقلاء إلى مجانين؟
شوف فيه أجزاء في الخلافات العقائدية؛ يتحوّل
بس بسيط
وطبعًا المصطلحات اللي في الجوانب العقائدية في الإعلام
أيضًا تراها مثيرة للجدل بشكل كبير
في أمثلة كثيرة ترى في الموضوع
على سبيل المثال
خليني أقول الأشياء العقائدية
الإعلام هل هو مجبر أن يقول على موت فلان من الناس شهيد؟
مثلًا؟ فيه ناس تبي تفرض عليك أن تكون شهيد
هذا خلاف صحفي عقائدي
خلاف مهني وعقائدي في نفس الوقت
هناك خلاف صحفي وميول
والميول أحيانًا يتحول إلى عقيدة عند كثير من الناس
عجيب! طيب
أيش آخر مباراة شفتها بما أنك هلالي؟
شفت «الهلال» و«الشباب» 2011
لا، الصدق!
شفت «الهلال» و«الرياض»؟
المباراة الأخيرة؟
إيه
90 دقيقة؟
ما أدري أيش تبي توصل له؟
لا، بس ماني مصدق أنك تتابع كرة
ليه؟
ما أدري كذا
ما عجبك؟
كثير أنا عندي من أصدقائي ترى يقول أنا هلالي، أنا نصراوي
تسأله، يقول ما أدري
أنا كنت أتجادل أنا وواحد من زملائنا قبل فترة
خل ناخذك ميدان ثاني
سوي اللي تبيه
كان يقول لي: أن «النصر» جاب صفقات أحسن من «الهلال»
والنصر مساعدينه أكثر من «الهلال»
وهذه الصفقات ومسكتينا
قلت له: طيب من الصفقات اللي جابهم «الهلال»؟
«سافيتش» وين يلعب قبل؟
قال: ما أدري
قلت له: «روبن» وين يلعب؟
قلت: طيب «مالكوم» وين يلعب؟
قال: ما أدري
قلت: طيب وحقين «النصر»؟
قال: أعرف «بروزوفيتش» كان يلعب في «الإنتر»
«ساديو ماني» كان يلعب في «ليفربول»
طبعًا ما قد جاب «النصر» من «ليفربول»
جاء من «بايرن ميونخ»
و«رونالدو» نعرفه كلنا وين يلعب
تجي تقيس على هذه المعلومات
كل المعلومات مقلية ترى
هو يقول لك «النصر» أفضل وللا «الهلال» أفضل
بدون ما يدخل في التفاصيل
هذا كثير في الرياضة، كثير بعد بتويتر
في كل المجالات أعتقد أنه موجود
لا والله في الرياضة طاغي
على الأقل خليني أقول لك لأنه ميداني
يمكن لأني قريب منه
طيب كنت بقول لك إلى الآن التعصب
هل الإعلام هو اللي أجّج التعصب؟
وللا التعصب هو اللي أبرز الإعلاميين؟
عملية مشتركة
والله؟
فيه كثير من الصحفيين وجودهم قايم على وجود التعصب
هم يغذون التعصب لأنه يحمي وجودهم
هو  لو كان يقف بين كل الأندية لم يصبح له قيمة
أتفق
لما صار ضد أو يحمي أو يحاول أن يحارب
ومع قضايا ناديه بس
صار له موقع في المدرج هذا
بس في المدرجات الثانية هو ما عنده موقع
هو ما يبحث أصلًا عن ذا الموقع
لأنه يعرف أنه لن يصل
التعصب هو ملح الكرة، وشيء موجود مهم
هذا الكلام يردده مو رياضيين كثير
وللا مرض يجري في أجسادهم
هو موجود موجود، شئنا أم أبينا
هو زين على فكرة في المدرجات
التعصب هو واحد من درجات الحب بالنسبة لي العالية جدًّا
اللي لا ترى العيوب ترى المحاسن فقط
قد يكون ذلك التعصب لمن تحب
هذا شيء من أعلى درجات الحب
التعصب هو جزئين أنا في ظني
واحد من دوافعه الحب
وواحد من دوافعه الكراهية
تجاه الآخرين هو كراهية
وتجاه من تحب أكيد حب قاطع
أنا أعتقد أن كثير من الإعلاميين
التعصب يحمي وجوده
وهذا واضح بشكل أو بآخر
ارتماء في حضن مدرج معين؛ يحافظ على بقاءه
لأنه لا يملك الأدوات اللي يثق في نفسه من خلالها
ما يمكن بأي حال من الأحوال أنك تقنع أحد متعصب
ترى هو في كل مكان
جماهير روما أظن الإيطالي
كان عندهم لاعب إسرائيلي
فرفعوا علمه في المدرجات
رفعوا علم إسرائيل
في نفس المدينة «لاتسيو» الفريق الثاني في المدينة
المباراة اللي بعدها رفعوا علم فلسطين
ما عندهم لاعب فلسطيني، ما عندهم أصلًا
فهذه مواضيع الضدية والندية اللي موجودة بين المدرجات
أنا أشوفها عادية في المدرجات، ما فيها أي مشكلة
هي متى ما انعكست على التقييم الحقيقي للعمل
سواءً العمل الإداري أو العمل الصحفي
أو العمل في اتجاه المنتخبات
هذه هنا لازم نقول توقف!
لازم يكون فيه أحد حازم يوقّف الموضوع
بس في المدرجات ما في مشكلة
أنا ما أرفض
من اللي يوقفهم؟
هل المفترض الدور الحكومي هنا
ضبط حالة التعصب وللا المفترض أنها تبتعد؟
والله عبدالرحمن أنا أشوف أن الحالة
والوضع الآن تحول إلى معسكرات
وما في أحد في الوسط في هذه المعسكرات يدير هذه العملية
أيًّ كانت رتبته، سواءً حكومية أو اجتماعية أو حتى رياضية
ما في أحد مقنع، ما في أحد قدوة في هذا الموضوع يقوم بهذا الدور
القواعد الصارمة، لما يمس الخطوط الحمراء أو الخطوط الحساسة
يجب أن تكون موجودة
أيش الخطوط الحساسة؟
يعني المنتخب الوطني
لا بد المفاهيم تكون واضحة
المنتخب هو المنتخب محد يشابهه كفريق
المنتخب هو من يمثلنا جميعًا
المنتخب اللي هو أنا والدي ما يحب الكرة، ما يتابع الكرة
ولكن إذا جاء وشافنا جالسين ونشوف
وقال: من يلعب؟
نقول له: السعودية وكذا
قال: عسانا فايزين؟
ما يحب الكرة، بس أن فيه شيء، دماء تتحرك لهذا الوطن
المنتخب لازم نقول قف للجميع
عندما تصل إلى مرحلة المنتخب
ولا بد أن تُسن قوانين في هذا الموضوع
وأنا أرجع وأقول: لا بد أن تكون المفاهيم واضحة
أنا وجهة نظري وهذه زعلت ناس مني
وما زلت أنا مؤمن بهذا الشيء
لا يوجد فريق يمثل الوطن إلا المنتخب
ليه؟
الفرق تمثل أنفسها
حتى لو كانت تمثل الوطن؟
حتى لو كانت في بطولة خارجية
حتى لو كانت في كأس العالم؟
حتى لو كانت في كأس العالم
هو الوحيد؟
هو الفريق هذا يمثل نفسه
عندي تعاطف
ولكن أرى أن في ذيك اللحظة يجب عدم الإساءة
احفظ لسانك على الأقل
لا تشجعه بس احفظ لسانك
لكن تجي تقول المنتخب لا يوازيه شيء
مهما كانت المشاركة
أيش يعني؟ مثلًا إذا أدّى أداء سيء ما أقول أنه أدى أداء سيء؟
لا، أنت الحين تتكلم عن الجمهور وللا الإعلام؟
الإعلام
الإعلام حتى المنتخب قال لنا سيء
ما في مشكلة
فوين الخط الأحمر؟
لا، أنا أتكلم عن الخط الأحمر اللي هي مشاكل الأندية
اللي يتم نقلها وتصديرها للمنتخب
المشاكل اللي تصير في المنتخب
ويتم تفسيرها بأن دوافعها من الأندية، هذه الأشياء
الصحافة اللي ممكن تلصق بلعيبة المنتخب
أشياء غير موجود فيها
محاولات التفرقة بين لعيبة المنتخب بشكل أو بآخر
حتى في المعلّقين، حتى في أشياء كثير
لا، المنتخب هو يمثلنا كلنا
يا أخي أنا مرة شفت مباراة
ما قد شفت في حياتي صراحة أحد في العالم العربي
يشجعون منتخبات بلدهم مثل المصريين والمغاربة
أنا شفت مباراة مرة المنتخب المصري في مصر
يا رجل الدنيا واقفة
مصر واقفة عند بكرة أبيها
بشكل ما يمكن وصفه في ذيك اللحظة
الشارع واقف، كل شيء في الدنيا واقف
المنتخب بيلعب
وتعال لما يجيب هدف، وللا يجي عليه هدف
وترى على فكرة يطلعون، ويزعلون على المنتخب
بس في الأخير كلهم خلف المنتحب
وترى عندهم مشاكل «أهلي» و«زمالك»
عندهم مشاكل كثيرة
وهذا موجود في منتخبات كثيرة
يمكن احنا ما نقول الأوربيين أقل في النظر إلى منتخباتهم بهذا الشكل
لأن الأوربيين أغلب لعيبتهم يلعبون في أندي غير محلية دائمًا
فالولاء لها ما يظهر
أجيب لك مثال مثلًا
«سيلفا» لاعب «مانشستر سيتي» البرتغالي
سووا معاه مقابلة، المقابلة تختار فلان أو فلان
يقول لك: لشبونة: «بانفيكا» ولا «بورتو» يختار
فكان من ضمن الأسئلة قال له
«إيزيبيو» اللي هو أسطورة البرتغال، وللا «رونالدو»
أسطورتهم في كأس العالم
بس مش أسطورة مقارنة بـ «رونالدو»
فقال: «رونالدو» لا شك بأنه أسطورة البرتغال على مر الأجيال
وأعظم من لعب كرة القدم في العالم
بس أنا أميل لـ«أزيبيو» عشان من النادي حقي
وهم مسوين له مجسم على بوابة النادي
فهذه موجودة، هذه التفريقات البسيطة
موجودة في كل مكان
بس أنا أقول المنتخب يجب أن لا يمس
المنتخب لازم يكون لها وضعه الخاص في التعامل معه
حتى في مواضيع العقوبات، ومواضيع القواعد
التعامل معه صحفيًّا، في كل شيء الصراحة
بس ليش استبعدته؟
أنا خلني بقول لك أيش يجي في بالي
استبعدت أيش؟
خليته على الجنب أنه لا يمكن لأحد
خصوصًا من الإعلاميين أو الصحفيين أن يتكلم عليه
النقد ما أمنعه
لا، ما يمكن أن أرفضه
قلت لك: شرحت لك عبدالرحمن بوضوح
إيه، خلني بقول لك
أيش اللي يمنع أن تكون ما ينطبق على المنتخب
ينطبق على كل الأندية؟
إذا أنت اتهمته بما ليس فيه؛ تعاقب القانون
بغض النظر أن نروح نسن قوانين جديدة
أنت اتهمته، هل عندك دليل؟ إذا عندك دليل...
أنت ترجعنا للسؤال اللي بالبداية
تراك سحبتنا الأفكار بعد اللي قلناه
أبد ما عليك
سحبتنا الأفكار كثير
بس أيش رأيك في هذه الفكرة؟
أن ما في أحد بعينه وإنما هو القانون على الجميع
لا، أنا قلت لك قبل شوي
ترى ما كانت هذه الفكرة الأساسية
بس نرجع الشريط نرجع نشوف؟
نرجع شريط شوي
التعصب كان
إيه، لا احنا نتكلم عن المنتخب
الجزئية اللي اخذتنا على المنتخب
اللي اخذتنا على المنتخب
أتوقع أنك بس كنت تبغى تستثنيه وتخليه على جنب
لا، ما كنت أبغى أستثنيه
لا، أنا أقول المنتخب يجب أن يكون له تعامل خاص
فما أمنع النقد، ترى ما أمنعه
أقول لك اليوم تطلع، تقول لي: المنتخب كان سيء
بس أنا قلت إدخال الميول في الحكم على المنتخب
هذه فكرتي بس
نقول مثلًا عبدالرحمن سيء لأنه نصراوي
اليوم ما لعب زين في المنتخب لأنه نصراوي
هذا غلط
طيب من اللي يحميه ذا النصراوي، وللا ذا الهلالي
وللا اللي من نادي «الفتح»؟
هذه فكرتي
ممتاز
وبعدين عرجنا...
طيب أيش رأيك في من يحكم؟
مثلًا أتذكر كان فيه مجلس الشورى طالب
رفع توصية أو شيء مثل كذا، والله أني ناسي
ودهم أنهم يسنون قانون لضبط التعصب
وعدم تشجيع التعصب في الإعلام وكذا
هل أنت مع وجود هذه القوانين اللي تمنع التعصب؟
وتحاول تقنيين الإعلام؟
أنا أشوف أنه ما يمكن السيطرة
بس احنا نتكلم هنا عن الإعلام ولا نتكلم عن الجمهور
الإعلام، الجمهور ما نتكلم عليه
الجمهور موجود في كل مكان
الجمهور، جمهور. أنا أتكلم عن الإعلام
الإعلام أنا أقول لك
عندنا أكثر من حل، وهذه مسيرة طويلة
تقديم القدوات الصحيحة
محاولة تعديل من حاد عن الطريق الصحيح في الإعلام
تقديم نموذج للنشء
حتى النشء لما يشوفون عبدالرحمن
قاعد يطبل كل ليلة لفريق «النصر»
ترى يحسبونك أنت الصح
تجي تقول لهم: المهنية كذا، واحد، اثنين، ثلاثة
يقولون: محد درى عنك أنت ومهنيتك ترى
وهذه حقيقة، هذه موجودة
فتقديم القدوات مهم
من اللي يقدمها؟
كثير
من هو دوره تقديمها؟
شوف التقديم، مو معناته أنك تاخذه بيده
فيه مواقف هي مواقف تقديمية
تتم في المجتمع بشكل أو بآخر
أنت لما تجي عبدالرحمن كل ليلة يطبل لـ «النصر»
تطبيل فاخر من النوع العظيم
اللي هو يحول السواد إلى بياض في زعمه
تجي أنت تقول: يا أخي هذا إنسان كويس
مقابلات وزير الرياضة بتروح عنده
مقابلات مدرب المنتخب بتروح عنده
بنسافر لكأس العالم بناخذه أول واحد
بنسافر للأولمبياد بناخذه أول واحد
أيش معنى هذا الكلام؟
تبارك ما يفعل، صح وللا؟
صح
هذا نوع من التقديم
كويس قلت صح يا عبدالرحمن
لا، ترى بنتفق كثير
بس أنت النصراوي عنده مشكلة أنه مظلوم دائمًا
شوفت؟
حتى بالإعلام وحتى وهو ضيفي
شوفت أيش هي منطلقاتك؟
أنا منطلقاتي منطلقات طيبة إن شاء الله
سم
«وليد الفراج» يقول في لقاء له برضه
الخمس سنين القادمة مفصلية في الإعلام الرياضي
يقول: ممكن كل الإعلام الرياضي التقليدي يختفي
واللي بيبقى فقط الأشخاص
هم اللي ممكن يتحولون لمنصات حقيقية للمعلومات
تتفق؟
لا، ما فهمت
مثلًا أقدر أجيب «خالد القحطاني»
هو شخص بذاته على الشبكات التواصل الاجتماعي
ويقوم مقام مؤسسات صحفية بالوصول والتأثير
ويقدم مادة تحليلية
لوحده في قناته؟
لوحده، سواءً في السناب أو في تويتر
تقدر برضه، أيش اسمه الأردني اللي على يوتيوب؟
محلل رائع وعنده ملايين المتابعات
وعلى ذلك فقس
اللي موجودين على شبكات التواصل الاجتماعي
وتأثيرك على التواصل الاجتماعي
قد يكون أحيانًا أعلى من «في المرمى»
اللي هو على «العربية» صحيح؟
ما عندي مقياس ثابت
نقدر نمشي في الفرضية هذه
أتوقع القصد، ترى أنا أنقل عنه
لا، أنا بسألك سؤال الحين
على موضوع المشاهدات المليونية أو المتابعات المليونية
أنا عندي متابعات مليونية، بس بقول ذا الكلام
طيب هل هي مقياس حقيقي؟
لا، مو كل المقياس، لكن معيار مهم
معيار
هل هو الأول؟
قد يكون أحيانًا، أنا بالنسبة لي لا شخصيًّا
طيب، بس متأكد أن في...
كل قيادات الإعلام ما عندهم متابعات مليونية
معليش ما فهمت
كل اللي يقودون المؤسسات الإعلامية في السعودية
في السعودية خلينا نقول
ما عندهم متابعة مليونية
مثل؟
مثلًا «أبو خالد وليد إبراهيم» ما عنده حساب في تويتر أصلًا
بس تختلف دوافعه
واحد من قيادات الـ «إم بي سي»
«علي جابر» ما عنده متابعات مليونية
ما في مشكلة يختلفون، بس لا تقدم...
ليش؟
«عبدالرحمن الراشد» هل أحد يشك في قامته
قيمةً وقدرًا وتاريخًا وإرثًا صحفيًّا حاضرًا وماضيًا؟
لا
ما عنده متابعات مليونية
ما في شك
إيه، بس لو أنت بتقدم برنامج وما يتابع
أنا متأكد أن «عبدالرحمن الراشد» في «العربية»
بيحذف برنامجك لو ما يجيب متابعات مليونية
لو كان مدير
لا، الحين هذا موضوع
أنا أتكلم عن المتابعات المليونية هل هي مؤشر؟
بس ليش يحذف البرنامج إذا كانت فيه مؤشر مهم
لا، أنا  أتكلم على وسائل التواصل الحين
فأنت خلطت موضوعين
احنا تكلمنا وأنت قلت لي واحد أردني عنده متابعات على حسابه
ترى أتوقع أنك تحبه، ما أتوقع أنك ...
والله ما أعرف من هو
والله أني ناسي اسمه
والله ما أعرف من هو، بس أنا أعرف «خالد القحطاني»
والنعم كفو، يقدم مادة جيدة
حسب متابعتي البسيطة، مش متابعة 100%
ولكن ممكن يكون واحد من أهم الناس
لو تم تأطير بعض الأشياء
بالقواعد المهنية اللازمة بس
مثلًا أنا شفت كثير من الناس على تويتر
ترى ممكن يكون على...
احنا الحين السؤال اللي نرجع نقوله حبيبنا
الافتقاد للقواعد المهنية هي أبسط صفات الإعلام الناشط
مش مطالب بها
مش مطالب بها، لكن برضه كونك على التلفزيون
قد يكون الآكشن هو أهم شيء تسويه
عند البعض، إيه
صح؟
عند البعض إيه، بس أنا ما أحبه
فلا يلزم ذلك
لا، أنا ما أحبه، بس عند البعض إيه
فيه فرق بين الإثارة الموضوعية
المادة أصلًا تقدر أنت تسويها
وفيه فرق بين الإثارة الفارغة
وفي كل مكان
وفيه إثارة فارغة على التلفزيون صح؟
فيه، لا شك
وجودك على التلفزيون لا يلزم أن تلتزم
بقواعد صحفية مهنية أو إعلامية مهنية
لا، هنا فرق يا حبيبنا
شوف لحظة خلني أقول لك شيء
بس عشان توصل لك الفكرة
احنا نتكلم عن القواعد الصحفية أساسًا المهنية
مو شرط أنها تكون في التلفزيون
مو شرط أن كل من في التلفزيون يتصف بها
بس هو المكان المناسب لها، لأن هذه مؤسسات
فيه فرق بين الفردي والمؤسسات
حتى على مستوى...
أنت تذكر زمان طلعت موضة اليوتيوبر وهذولي الإعلام الناشط
وين راحوا الآن؟
يعني
فيه وفيه، فيه من اختفوا ومن استمروا على بطئ
بس أغلب من استمروا، ليه ما راحوا مؤسسات؟
ليه ما راحوا مؤسسات؟
اللي راحوا مؤسسات، الغالبية العظمى
اللي تحولوا إلى مؤسسات
الجانب الفردي منهم أغلبهم اختفى
أنا عندي وجهة نظر، أن حتى الإعلام الناشط هذا
متى ما تحول إلى مؤسسات؛ بيكون إعلام حقيقي
بس المشكلة أيش هو ؟
يا عبدالرحمن، هذا شيء ترى والله مهم جدًّا
كثير ينظرون للإعلام بأنه عملية سهلة سطحية
أي أحد ممكن يقوم بها
كذا لما ينظر لها نظرة من الخارج
بس لما تدخل في عمق الإعلام من الداخل
هذه عملية معقدة إلى أبعد الحدود
ترى أحيانًا أنت ممكن تتقابل مع مسؤول كبير
ومع مسؤول صغير، ومع رجل الشارع
وهو ينظر للإعلام نفس النظرة هذه
بس تعال قل له: ترانا سوينا هذه كذا لكذا
فما يدري أن هذه العملية تمت بهذا الشكل
ومرت بهذه المراحل حتى تصل له
وهذا شيء من الأسف الشديد
تكاد تكون نظرة عامة في الفترة الأخيرة تجاه الإعلام
يجيك واحد يقول لك
إيه، أنت والإعلام، أنا بالتليفون سويت الهوائل
احنا ما نلغي وجود مثل هؤلاء الناس
لكن لا بد أن نعرف أن الإعلام أيضًا مهنة لها قواعدها
ومهنة لها إجراءاتها، ومهنة لها حدودها
ومهنة لها قيمها
ما يصلح أنت أن تقول
والله واحد جاء أمس صحى من النوم
وفتح له حساب على السناب أنه صحفي
ما يمكن
احنا ما نلغي وجودك، أنت موجود
لكن لست صحفي
بس ممكن تكون إعلامي، وللا ناشط؟
شوف ترى أنا من اللي شفته عندك في الحلقة
أنت سألته نفس السؤال
حتى قال لك: ما أدري هم إعلاميين وللا مو إعلاميين
والله ناسي
ممكن «عبدالرحمن الراشد» ما أدري والله
أظنه «عبدالرحمن»؟
يمكن والله
يمكن
أتوقع هذا كلامه
والله أنا نفس الشيء، تصدق؟
ما أعرف، إذا تجي على المهنية
ما فيها أي سبل أو طرق تُسلك للمهنية
أنت أحيانًا تقول: بعض جوانب المهنية هما لا يحتاجونها
الحقيقة صحيح
طيب أيش المعايير؟
إذا أبغى أرجع برضه للأشخاص أصبحوا منصات
ممكن نقول أن المشاهدات معيار، التأثير معيار
أيش باقي عشان تصبح منصة
صحفية؟
صحفية أو إعلامية؟
هي الخطوط والله تحس أن الموضوع متشربك بشكل أو بآخر
احنا يمكن حقين الإعلام التقليدي
ندافع وننافح عن هذه المهنة
وفيه واحد يجيك يبسطها
يقول: يا أخي تراك أزعجتنا بهذه المهنية حقك
أيش المهنية؟ ترى ما درى عنها إلا اثنين، ثلاثة
وماتوا، خلاص ما بقي منهم أحد
فأنت يوم تجي تنظر للمشهد تقول
والله عنده جانب من الصحة
صدق ترى ما أحد درى عن المهنية اللي أنت قاعد...
بس هي يا أخي عبدالرحمن نوع من الرضا الذاتي في المهنة
أنت لما تجي تعمل بمهنتك بقواعدها وأساليبها وتنافح عنها
هذا نوع من الرضا الذاتي الداخلي
لما تجي، وواحد قاعد يعلم الناس بشكل خاطئ عن المهنة
أنت تستشيط غضبًا، تحاول أن تنافح عن حدودها
لأنك ترى أنه انتهكت
وهذا اللي يتم الآن بين كثير من التداخلات
اللي بين المنصات الفردية اللي يرون أنفسهم إعلاميين
كثير مثلًا من إعلاميين الإعلام التقليدي وقعوا في المحظور
ليش؟ لأن الإعلامي أساسًا، ما أقول دائمًا
ولكن غالبًا، الإعلامي الحقيقي المهني
يستطيع الرقص على الخطوط الحمراء دون أن يقع
كثير منهم الحين موقوفين مثلًا لسبب أو لآخر لأخطاء فادحة
وبعضها على فكرة أخطاء سطحية
هذا أيضًا وحدة من الفروق اللي أنا ممكن أقيّم المشهد على أساسها
طيب، معليش
أنت مع مين أنت؟ الإعلام القديم وللا الجديد؟
أنا بستخدم نفس عبارتك
أنا هنا المذيع، أنا اللي اسأل
ما قلتها هذه، وين قلتها؟
قلتها
وين؟
مع «أبو ناصر» في لقائك يوم بدأ يسألك
والله أني ناسي
طبعًا ناسي، لكن أنا ودي اسأل
هل تتعارض المهنية مع استخدام أدوات الإنترنت الجديدة؟
أبدًا
طيب، وراك؟
أبدًا، احنا نتكلم عن المهنية
المهنية ماهي بالمنصة؟
وراهم قادرين ينافسونكم وأنتم مؤسسات؟
شوف الصحافة هي الصحافة في كل مكان، تختلف الأداة
مثلًا الصحافة الورقية كانت الأداة أيش؟ القلم
صح
الصحافة الإلكترونية كانت الأداة لوحة المفاتيح، صح؟
الصحافة التلفزيونية، الكاميرا والمايك
هي الصحافة، الأداة تختلف
الحين أقول لك مثلًا الموضوعية
ما هي اشتراطات الموضوعية؟
مثلًا أن تقف على نقطة من البُعد متساوية بين طرفي القضية
أن تنقل الخبر كما هو بدون تدخل
من رغباتك الشخصية ومنافعك الخاصة
أن تكون قريبًا من المشهد اللي تنقله مثلًا
هي كثير طبعًا الاشتراطات
البعض يقول: أن حتى فيها اشتراطات فرعية
اللي هي: لا بد أن لا تنقل عن ناقل
فيه اشتراطات كثيرة
كتابة الخبر الصحفي
خلينا نتكلم على موضوع الصحافة الإلكترونية
وصلنا في مرحلة من المراحل في البلد
أي واحد عنده لابتوب ويفتح موقع
يقول: أنا رئيس تحرير
مرينا في هذه الفترة وللا لا؟
وبعدين جات وزارة الإعلام وسوت تنظيم
سووا تنظيم في ذيك المرحلة
أن من يفتح موقع لهم الاشتراطات التالية وصار فيه تنظيم
احنا نتكلم الخبر حتى
يا عبدالرحمن، لما تجي تقرأ في بعض المواقع
الخبر ما تعرف رأسه من قفاه
حتى الخبر هذا لما يُنسج كخبر
الخبر يفرق عن التقرير
الخبر لا بد أن يبدأ بفعل
لا بد أن يبدأ بافتتاحية، ما فيه تفاصيل
ثم المتن يكون فيه التفاصيل
ثم التصريح، ثم الخاتمة
يكون فيه خلفية لما سبق
هذه الأشياء ما تكتب بشكل أو بآخر
العناوين في الصحافة ما يجب أن يكون فيها حرفين جر
الصورة في الصحافة ما تبدأ من اليمين
العنوان ما يكون فيها أسماء موصولة
هذه قواعد مهنية، هل هي موجودة في الصحافة الإلكترونية؟
أنت أدرى
أنت مو إعلامي بعد؟
هل كسرت هذه القواعد؟
طيب أنا أسألك سؤال من الجهة الثانية
من المعسكر الثاني، هل هي مهمة أساسًا وللا لا؟
هل هذه القواعد مهمة وللا كسرها؟
ترى ما كسرنا المِلة، بيقول لك واحد
إذا هو يعرفها وكسرها؛ ما عندي مشكلة
ما عندك مشكلة؟
إذا هو كسرها لغرض معين
لأن أنا ضد تقديس القواعد
لا، مو تقديس القواعد
كل مهنة لها أصولها
إيه، أهم شيء أنك تعرف أصولها
ومن ثم عاد سوي اللي تبيه
أجل أيش استفدنا من معرفتك؟
أنك تدري وتدرك أن هذا...
إذا بنجلس خلاص هكذا وجدنا أباءنا عليها
لا مو هكذا وجدنا
التطور يأتي في المفردة، التطور يأتي في التناول
بس هذا مو سؤالي
مو بسؤالك، بس أنا سؤالي كان
بس أنا بقول لك: أنت تعرف الأدوات المهنية الصحفية وأنتم أهلها
أنا صحفي، أنا لا أملك مؤسسة صحفية
أنت تدير مؤسسة صحفية
المفروض
إيه، ما المانع من أنكم تستخدمون أدوات الإنترنت الجديدة؟
من قال لك ما نستخدمها؟
بتال تنزلون «بي دي إف» تغريدة!
لا، من اللي قالك ما ننزله؟
هذا جزء
أنت جيت على 1%
طيب نافسهم، أنا ما عندي مشكلة تدري
لحظة خلني بجيك على «الرياضية»
مو برايح «العربية»
«الرياضية» عندها قسم خاص بوسائل التواصل
صح؟
إيه، عندها قسم الإلكتروني
«الرياضية» في المناسبات تغطي سناب
وتغطي إنستقرام، تغطي إكس أو تويتر
إكس الناس لسه ما تعودوا عليها، وتغطي تويتر
وتغطي الموقع وتغطي ورقيًّا
طبعًا آخر المراحل اللي قلتها لك
أكيد أن المرحلة الورقية ليست الأولى ولا الثانية ولا الثالثة الآن
والله؟
حتى الموقع الإلكتروني، نكون جادين
لكن احنا نغطيها مهنيًّا
نغطيها بالطريقة المهنية
أنت الحين يا عبدالرحمن
هذه واحدة من القواعد مثلًا
لو جاك رئيس نادي «الهلال»
وأعطاك تصريح ضد رئيس لجنة الانضباط مثلًا
أرجو أنه ما يفهمني اخترت رئيس «الهلال»
بس جات في بالي كذا عشانك
لما يجيك التصريح بهذا الشكل
من المهنية أنك تذهب لرئيس لجنة الانضباط
تقول: عندنا تصريح كذا كذا، هل لديكم رد؟
هو أمام ثلاث خيارات
أما يقول لك لا تعليق، فهذا رد
لا تعليق هو رد، هو تعليق
أو يسكّر التلفون في وجهك
قصدي أنه ما يستجيب
وهذا رد
وهذا مو رد، هذا تنتظر شوي
أو لا يعطيك رد
أنك تنشر بدون الرد
هذا أحيانًا عيب مهني فيه جزء من الانحياز
مثل هذه الأشياء ماهي موجودة عند الزملاء الجدد
هو ينقل وبس
احنا مثلًا الآن لما نستخدم الإعلام الجديد
في «الرياضية» كمؤسسات
وأنا من خلال اسئلتك
عرفت أنك غير متابع لـ «الرياضية» بشكل كويس لتغطياتها
فاحنا لما نروح نسأل حتى في وسائل التواصل
في المنصات الجديدة
احنا نلتزم بالخط المهني
أنا ما أشك في مهنيتكم والله
لا، أنا أشك في متابعتك
ما عندي مشكلة، شك مثل ما تريد
بس أني أشك في مهنيتك
أنا أشك في متابعتك تعرف ليش؟
لأنك أنت تقول: أنت تنزلون...
هذه جزء
بس أنا بالنسبة لي المشكلة...
أنت تعرف أن الخبر...
لا، بس هذا اللافت، أكيد أنكم تنشرون
لا، أرائك الخاصة لا تعممها
لا، بس أنت لما تشوفها؛ أنا انتقادي على هذه الجزئية
أول شيء عبدالرحمن
ترى أحبكم واجد ما عليك
بغض النظر، هذه ذاتية وهذه موضوعية
بما أننا نحكي عن الموضوعية والذاتية
المحبة لا شك فيها، أبد القلوب عند بعض
ولكن احنا نتكلم في إطار علمي مهني
إيه ما فيه مشكلة
بشكل أو بآخر
أنا أشوف أنك غير متابع جيد لما تأخذ هذه كاستشهاد
لأن حتى الـ«بي دي إف»
اللي أنت شايف الخبر الرئيسي اللي هو خبر الليلة
يتم تقسيمه، يعني ينزل كتقسيم
أساسًا الصحافة الورقية جذورها عميقة في أنفس الناس القدماء
لما تجي أنت تبي تحولهم
تقول: يا أخي ترى أنا مسوّي موقع إلكتروني
وأغطي في المنصات دي وأغطي في كل شيء
يقول لك: العنوان ليش ما كتبت اليوم عن «النصر»؟
ترى أنا مغطي هناك إلين قلنا بس
يقول لك: لا، لا
ترى العنوان جزء بسيط من عمل طول اليوم قاعد يصير
أنا أيش في يدي أسوي عشان أقنع الناس في هذا الموضوع؟
ولا شيء
تفضل عبدالرحمن عطنا وجهة نظرك
ما عندي وجهة نظر، أنا مجرد...
لما أنا شوف «بي دي إف» يلفت انتباهي
ليش الشباب مسويين مثل كذا؟
قريت ما بعده؟
أنا أشوف التغريدات كلها، بس هذه...
قريت ما بعده، قرأت ما قبله؟
شوفت أيش مناسب؟
إيه، أنا أشوفكم تنزلون كثير، وتعيدون تغريد كثير
لا، أنا أعيد تغريد والله كثير
أنا بالعكس مشغول بالإعلام الآن أكثر من إعادة التغريد
لا، القصد أني أشوفها
بس هذيك عادية، ولأنها عادية فأنا ما ناظرت لها
بس هذه اللي لفتتني فلذا...
معليش، قل لي الجزئية اللي عندك احتجاج عليها
وجود «بي دي إف» في تغريدة بس
لافت، ما عندي احتجاج
طيب، أيش نقطة أو مصدر دهشتك؟
أنك تنزل صورة الصفحة الرئيسية مثل ما هي
هل باقي أحد يقراه؟
يمكن أنت عندك معلومات أنا ما أدركها
لحظة، أول شيء أنت ما عندك حد ائتماني لموضوع التغريدات
أبدًا، سوي اللي تبي
أنت تنزّل الصفحة الأولى ثم تفصلها خبريًّا، ليش؟
ليش؟
عبدالرحمن أنت لو اشتغلت في الصحافة الورقية
بتحب شيء اسمه الإخراج الصحفي
أفهمك والله، رغم أني ما اشتغلت فيه
هذه وحدة من أمتع فنون الصحافة
من أمتع أمتعها، ومن أعظم رؤساء التحرير
اللي هو دائمًا يرسمه بنفسه
مثلًا مثل «محمد تونسي»
تخيل رئيس التحرير يمسك النموذج حق الصفحة
والمرسم ويرسم الصفحة
أنا ما اشتغلت مع «عبدالرحمن» مثلًا ولا «عثمان» صحافة ورقية
ما أدري والله هم يرسمون وللا لا
ولا قد سولفت معهم
بس هم طبعًا الثلاثي اللي...
ولا «خالد المالك» ولا «تركي السهيل» الله يرحمه
رموز صحافتنا الورقية كانوا
ومنهم من تحول بعدين إلى صحافة العصر الجديدة وانسجم معها
ومنهم من توقف
فهذا واحد من الفنون
إذن احنا أيش المانع يا حبيبنا
أن نقدم هذا الفن في تغريدة صفحة «بي دي إف»
ثم نذهب نفصّل أو فصلنا قبلها ونزلنا
استمتع بإخراج الصفحة وبعنوانها
ثم الخبر وزعناه لك، أنت اللي ما تحب الصفحة الأولى
على تغريدات أخرى تقرأها مباشرة
واستمتع فيها بذوقك
هذا ذوق وهذا ذوق
لكن لم نقدمه على فكرة كعنوان رئيسي للجريدة
لم نقدمه كالعمل الأبرز للجريدة
لكن عمل ما نقدر نتجاهله
احنا يوميًا على سبيل المثال
عندنا شيء اسمه «صورة اليوم» ينزل على تويتر
تعرف ليه سويناها؟
ليه؟
سويناها لأن عندنا كثير من الصور مثلًا نحب نستثمرها
غير الانستقرام، ونبي نشجع الصورة
واحد من أجمل الصورة الصحفية؛ فنون الصحافة
وفيه مسابقات عالمية لها، وفيه وفيه
خلينا نقول من الأشياء اللي قل تأثيرها في الفترة الأخيرة
لكن الصورة في الصحافة شيء عظيم
المصورين لا يقلون أن لم يكن يتفوقون في الصحافة
على الصحفي نفسه
يا أخي صورة وحدة عن ألف خبر
في هذه الفترة هل هذا الفن موجود؟
حاولنا نحييه
ترى على فكرة الشركة السعودية الـ «إس آر إم جي»
كان عندها يوم من الأيام مجلة بس خاصة بالصور
أيش كان اسمها؟
«فوكس» أظن أو شيء مثل كذا
والله ناسي اسمها
بس الصورة أكيد ما في شك
هذا الحديث جرنا على فنون كثيرة من الصحافة
أنا أعلم وأنت تعلم، وكثير من المشاهدين الآن يعلمون
أن الناس ما عاد تقرأ المقالة المطولة وهذه الأشياء
لكن هناك من يستمتع بها
السؤال، أما تزال تقرأ روايات؟
الرواية كم؟ 500 صفحة
أقل رواية 200 صفحة أو 220 مثلًا
بس مستمتع، ولها وقتها الخاص
الخبر المطول ما أصبح عنده قارئ
بس التقرير الصحفي
أنا ما أقول لك تحوّل الجريدة الثلاث صفحات كلها تقارير صحفية
وكل تقرير 500 كلمة أو 400 كلمة؛ لا
لكن لا بد يكون هذا موجود
خلّه موجود، جزء من السلطات
وجزء من الأطباق اللي موجودة على السفرة
اللي بغى يأكل، واللي بغى يحطّه في الثلاجة ويأكلها بكرة
ما في مشكلة
بس هذه الفنون موجودة يجب أن لا تموت
الخبر الصحفي السريع اللي صار
العواجل شلون وجدت؟
العواجل وجدت يا أخي لأن الصحافة الورقية أصبح هناك من يسبقها
فما صار عندها فرصة أنها تصيغ الخبر بالشكل المتكامل
اللي هو افتتاحية الخبر، القصة، التفاصيل
المتن أو السند ثم الخاتمة
ما في وقت
الناس قد مداهم عرفوا الخبر، وإن تكتب ذا الخبر!
فأصبح هناك عواجل في الصحافة وفي التلفزيون
صحيح
أيضًا الصحافة تطور نفسها
من خلال أدوات جديدة تحاكي العصر
ليش احنا لما ننزل الصفحة الأولى وننزل الصفحة الأخيرة
وللا نغطيها بهذا الشكل، يقول لك اخطيتوا؟
بقول لك قصة ترى مهمة
فيه واحد عنده مناسبة مهمة صحفية ما تجاملها فيها
غطيناها على الموقع الإلكتروني
فقلت له: هذه التغطية
قال: لا، وين العنوان؟
هذا اللي أنت رافعه؟
ما يزالون الناس...
تتناقش مع الناس أن يا جماعة هي مش بالمتر
في التغطيات مش بالمتر ترى
يقول لك: لا، العنوان
كثير من الصحف حول العالم حتى في السعودية
كثير من الصحف توقفت، أصبحت «بي دي إف» على الموقع
هي تشتغل مواقع إلكترونية
فيها تغطيات وأخبار ومقالات وأراء
بس الـ «بي دي إف» موجود
استمرارية الـ«بي دي إف» نوع من الإرث
نوع من الجمالية الإخراجية
فكرة رومانسية
فكرة رومانسية للناس اللي يحاولون يكسرون القواعد المهنية
لأن ما يجدون لهم طريق فيها مثلًا
أيش فيك عبدالرحمن؟
ولا شيء، طيب
ما أدري ليش تعتقد أنها...
لا، تقولها
لا، بقولها
لا، تقول أشياء أنا ما قلتها، وتحولها إلى حقائق في الحوار
حقائق نقطعها ونضبطها ونحطها في منتج ممتاز
تفضل
أن الأدوات الجديدة بمختلفها
أنت ليش تصورني علي أني رافضها؟
لأنك أنت يوم قلت لك تحطها...
قمت أنت تقول تبي تكسرها
لا، أنا رافض كسر القواعد المهنية على كل المنصات
اشتغل بأي منصة تبيها بس لا تكسر القواعد
*(...)
إيه، بس هذه مهنة
أبد، بس اللي حط الفكرة دي؛ تقدر تطور عليها
بضرب لك مثال
في «الشرق الأوسط» صحيفة عريقة
جذروها في التاريخ كمدرسة
أسلوب «الشرق الأوسط» لا تكتب بأسلوب مثلًا «الاقتصادية»
وهم في نفس الشركة، ليش؟
المتلقي، الأهداف تختلف
«الشرق الأوسط» عندها لغتها
«الاقتصادية» عندها لغتها
«الرياضية» عندها لغتها
كتاب أسلوب «الرياضية» مختلف عن كتاب أسلوب «الشرق الأوسط»
تمامًا
حتى في كتابة الشهور أبسط شيء
هذه الأشياء اللي أقولها لك
ترى ما ينتبه لها القارئ العادي
هذه من الأشياء لأهل التخصص، كل المهن
عبدالرحمن لا تروح بعيد
الآن على التيك توك مثلًا وللا على سناب
كم عدد الناصحين طبيًّا؟
كثير
مهنيين؟
لا
شكرًا
ليه؟
أنا محب وممارس للرياضة حتى الآن
وأهتم لدرجة الهوس بالتغذية، وأشاهد كثير من الأشياء
ماني بقول لك أني...
بس أنا بالخبرة من سنين
وأسأل الأطباء ومختصين بالمجال
كثير من الأشياء اللي تقال غلط
وكثير من الأشياء اللي تقال متناقضة
إذن احنا لازم نحافظ في كل المهن على قواعدها
أنت لا تفهم التمسك بالقواعد ضد التطور
لا تفهمه، وأرجو أن ما يفهمه أحد من مستمعينا
أبدًا مو ضد التطور
أنت ممكن تتطور، ولكن الحفاظ على الهوية
حتى الهوية ما عندي مشكلة فيها
أتكلم على قواعد المهنة، شيء ضروري جدًّا
يوم أطلقت «شمس» هل جوك صحفيين آخرين من الصحف الثانية
وقالوا: أن اللي أنت تسويه غير مهني؟
وأنك جالس (...)*
ما كانوا حابين موضوع «التابلويد»
بس على فكرة «التابلويد» ليس ضد الصحافة مهنيًّا
عُرفت في الصحافة الغربية بأن «التابلويد» صحافة فضائح
ليست صحافة رصينة ولا صحافة رسمية
الحجم عُرف بهذا الشكل، أُخذت عنه صورة
مثل الألوان يا عبدالرحمن الألوان فيه صورة عنها
اللون الأحمر في صورة عنه كذا، اللون الأخضر إلى آخره
هي صور نمطية في أذهان الناس
أيضًا صحافة «التابلويد» كان فيه صورة نمطية عنه
كان هذا اختلاف بيننا وبين كثير من رؤساء تحرير الكبار في ذيك الفترة
بس مو معناته أننا ما كنا مهنيين
أنا ما قلت أنك ما أنت بمهني
بس بالنسبة لآخرين كنت منت مهني
لا
لا؟
لا، فيه نقطة فيها سوء تفاهم بيني وبينك في الموضوع للآن
يمكن
أبغى أقول لك وأحدد لك شيء
الحفاظ على القواعد المهنية ليس ضد التطور
هذه لازم نتفق عليها
ممتاز، فالقواعد تتطور
لحظة خلني أقول لك شيء
المنصات تتطور، القواعد ليست قرآن مقدس
والدليل يا عبدالرحمن فيه قواعد أساسية وفيه قواعد فرعية
القواعد الأساسية هي الصحافة
القواعد الأساسية كتابة الخبر
هذه القواعد الأساسية إلى آخره
بس يا أخي أنا قلت لك قبل شوي
عن الأختلافات بين المدارس الصحفية
«الشرف الأوسط» و«الاقتصادية»
و«الحياة» سابقًا كانت مدرسة صحافية
وهم كانوا كلهم صحافيين حقيقيين، بس هذه مدارس
موجود في كل المهن الاختلاف
ما بنختلف
تحمست أنا شوي
طيب أيش رأيك في اختلافك مع أبو محمد مع «داود»
إيه؟
ليش هو نظر للفكرة بهذه الحيثية؟
أنا متأكد أنه ما تابعه
يمكن تابع عدد وما تابع اللي قبله
تابع تغطية باكتشاف أن هو صفحة أولى
بس ما شاف الموقع
وهذه معاناة نعانيها مع كثير من الناس
مثل ما قلت لك قبل شوي، يقول لك: العنوان
يا أخي العنوان ترى حالة تتم الساعة 12:00 بالليل بس
الباقي ما قبلها فيه أشياء كثيرة غطيناها
الناس ما تتابع هذا الشيء
أنا ملزم مش أن نطق بيوت الناس
ونقول: ترى كتبنا هذا الشيء
أكيد أننا منّا ملزمين
في نفس الوقت الناس لهم الحق يعبرون عن أراؤهم
ولهم الحق يعبرون عن ما يرونه صحيح
سواءً «داود» أو غيره
لكن إذا وضّح لهم؛ فالحق أحق أن يُتبع، سواءً معي ولا ضدي
أيضًا أنا ما عندي مشكلة يا عبدالرحمن
ما أعتقد أني أنا إنسان أرفض الرأي الآخر
أنا في الصحافة لي سنين، بالعكس أتقبّل كل الآراء
لكن قدّم لي رأيك بصيغة تعبّر أو تنبي عن الاحترام
لا تتبجح ولا تنتفخ على الآخرين
كأنك أنت تعلم كل شيء وهم لا يعلمون
ناقشني بكل احترام، وأناقشك بكل احترام
سواءً أنا اختلفت
وبعدين مثل ما قلت أنت في البداية
هي ترى قواعد مش قرآن مقدس إذا كسرناها بندخل النار
لا، ممكن أنا وياك نختلف بس كلنا محترمين
بلا شك، إذن لا تتبجح وأنت تقدم رأيك للناس
ولا تنتفخ على الآخرين
قدمه بكل احترام ونحترمك
وحتى ممكن ما نرد، نقبل وما نرد
أنت تقول ما عندك مشكلة مع الاختلاف
واضح عندك مشكلة مع الاختلاف
مثلًا؟
هذا على الأقل
أنا قاعد أناقشك
الحين أنت تبيني أقبل بس رأيك
علشان أثبت لك أني مش مختلف معك؟
نعم
نعم؟!
ما أدري يمكن «النصر» مأثر عليك ما أعرف والله
بس جاي...
«النصر» كويس دي الفترة، وشلون يأثر علي؟
المفروض له تأثير إيجابي طيب
«النصر» هي حالة، ماهي ...
شفت أنك ما تتابع؟
أيش دعوة، شايف مباراة أمس
لا، ما تتابع
جعلني ما تابعت
«النصر» من عرفته وهم مظلومين
مظلومين؟
شوف المظلومية في الوسط الرياضي شعار دارج
عند كل من ما يكون كويس اليوم
«الهلال» مو مظلوم دائمًا
ما يظلم؟
يظلم تارات
ترى هذا اعتراف خطير ضدك مو بصالحك
لا، أبدًا الهلاليين موضعيين
إيه، بس أقول لك هذا اعتراف خطير ضدك مو لصالحك
ما عليك مني، أنا ما أمثل كل الهلاليين
تمثلهم؟
لا، ما أمثلهم
أقول لك أنت تدور الزلة
لا والله
تدور الزلة وأنت خابرني كفو
لا والله وأنت كفو وستين كفو
ليش ما فيه صحف أو مشاريع رياضية جديدة
طلعت في المشهد خلال فترة الماضية؟
بينما تقدر تشوف مشاريع في مجالات ثانية
في الثقافة وللا في الفن
حتى ممكن أحيانًا في السياسة إلا الرياضة
رغم أن شعبيتها عالية، ممكن يكون فيها فلوس أكثر
إلا أنك ما تقدر تشوف مشاريع مستقلة جديدة في المجالات الرياضية
تكلم عن مستوى المنصات؟
مستوى المنصات
مثل «ثمانية» ماهي مشروع رياضي
هو مشروع تقدر تسميه ثقافي
وفيه مشاريع كثيرة في مجالات مختلفة
لكنني ما أتذكر مشروع رياضي
فليش هذا الغياب منها؟
إذا كنا نتكلم عن مشروع رياضي أنه منصات جديدة
طلعت «إس إس سي» مثلًا، مشروع جديد
بس هذا مشروع مو مستقل
«إس إس سي» تابع لوزارة الرياضة أو تشرف عليه وزارة الرياضة؟
أظن كان
بس أنها من رحم...
بس هذا مشروع جديد
بس أنا أقصد مستقل
ما أعرف والله أيش الأسباب
يمكن رؤوس الأموال ما عندها ثقة في المشاريع الرياضية
يمكن هذا واحد من الأسباب
يمكن أيضًا الرياضة دائمًا تدخل ضمن التفاصيل
وليست عنوان مستقل
مثلًا «ثمانية»
مثل ما قلت أنت مشروع ثقافي ولكن يستضيف رياضيين
ففي داخله الرياضة وليست عنوانه العريض
يمكن يكون هذا السبب
يمكن رؤوس الأموال
الرياضيين ترى طفارى مو مثل المثقفين
والله؟
ما توكل عيش الرياضة
أجل الاستثمار في الرياضة مربح على كذا
ممكن أنت كمستثمر فكر
ليش لا؟ بالعكس
فيه جانب في الرياضة أنا شوف ما أحد طرقه
الشغل الوثائقي في الرياضة ما هو موجود
أو موجود بشكل بسيط جدًّا
على فكرة، من أنجح الأفلام الدرامية الأمريكية
أفلام رياضية كثير ناجحة إلى أبعد الحدود
فيه، ما أدري إذا شفت «الرقصة الأخيرة» مثلًا حق «مايكل جوردين»
رائع جدًّا، وانتشر انتشار النار في الهشيم
لا، أنا ما أتكلم عن الأفلام الوثائقية لشخصيات
لا، أنا أتكلم على أفلام رياضية درامية
مثل؟
ناسي والله عناوين، قاعد أتذكر وأنت تتكلم
بس فيه موجود
بس الأكيد أنه فيه
الأكيد أن فيه وهي ناجحة
تلقى قبول
في العالم العربي ما في أفلام وثائقية جيدة
حتى تخيل يا عبدالرحمن أن رموز للرياضة
مثل «ماجد عبدالله» «سامي الجابر» «محمد نور»
أنا كنت بطلع من الكرة بس أنت رجعتنا
كنت بطلع مثلًا بقول «سعد شداد» «خالد العيد» «دهامي رمزي»
هذولي عندهم ميداليات أولمبية
أهم الميدالية الأولمبية من لعبة جماعية أخرى
تخيل ما عندهم أفلام وثائقية
سوينا واحد مع «هادي صوعان»
«هادي صوعان»
سوينا فيلم وثائقي
هو ممتاز «هادي صوعان»
بسألك أنت منت متابع جيد
ما تتابع «ثمانية» بشكل جيد
لا، أتابع والله
الحقيقة أنا مش متابع بشكل ممتاز
ولكني متابع
الله يحفظك يارب
طيب ليش متمسك بـ«العربية»؟
أنا بقولك ليش
عندك فرصة وظيفية؟
عندي فرصة وظيفية
لا والله، بس دائمًا أستغرب ليش «العربية» هي قناة
عندها وصول عالي وكل شيء ما نختلف
لكنها نخبوية، يتابعها النخبة ويتابعها الساسة
ويتابعها الناس
كويس
لكن الرياضة ماهي جوههم
قد يكون الرياضيين في أماكن ثانية
إذا أنت تحت منظومة «إم بي سي»
هذا جيد عبدالرحمن، إذا أنا في قناة نخبوية
وأصبحوا يتابعوني رياضيًّا
هذا شيء ممتاز
ما جات فكرة ببالك، ليش تمسكت بـ «العربية»؟
يمكن «إم بي سي 1»
والله أنا يمكن الوصف، أنا أحب الرياضة
ما في شك، ما أنكر هذا الشيء
أحب الرياضة ممارسة، وأحب الرياضة متابعة
ولكن إذا جينا إلى جهات الإعلام أرجع وأقول لك
وصف لزميلنا «صالح الخليف» الله يذكره بالخير
كان دائمًا يقول: أنا صحفي يعمل في الرياضة
ولست صحفي الرياضة
أنا إلى حدٍ ما شبيه بهذا القول، خليني أقول لك
أنا أحب الصحافة بشكل ما أعرف أشتغل غيرها
حاولت أن أكون رجل أعمال وفشلت فشل ذريع
بعدين أقول لك إياها تحت الهواء
ما يمكن أكون، وما أعرف غير هذه المهنة
اشتغلتها وأنا طالب في الجامعة
وتدرجت فيها من الصحافة الورقية
الإلكترونية، المنصات إلى الإعلام التلفزيوني
أنا كان لي خطين مسارين متوازين
ما بين الصحافة الورقية والتلفزيونية في نفس الوقت
وحتى إذاعة اشتغلت
ما في منصة إعلامية ما اشتغلت فيها
أحبها وأستمتع فيها
ما يمنع أن تمر بحالات احباط
مثلك مثل أي إنسان يعمل في كل مكان
يمر أحيانًا حالات نفسك أنك ما مشيت في هذا الخط
ولكن هي خُطى ولا بد أن تكملها
«العربية» أنا بالنسبة لي واحدة من أهم قلاع المهنية الحقيقة
أسست على ذلك واستمرت
أكيد أنها مرت بلحظات وهن، وبلحظات ضعف
مثلها مثل كل المجموعات اللي في العالم
ومثلها مثل أي جسم إعلامي موجود
يمر بلحظة صحة أو لحظة مرض
ولكن أنا ما زلت أقول أنها من أهم القلاع المهنية وليست الإعلامية
عندها هوية، عندها شخصية، عندها قواعد واضحة
أنا فخور أني اشتغلت في «العربية» وما زلت
أنا متمسك فيها، وممكن هم متمسكين فيني أيضًا
أظن وأعتقد
الإنسان يغادرها؟
لا، الصحفي يتخلى عن مهنيته
كيف يتعامل مع الأخبار اللي لها علاقة بالوطن مثلًا؟
يكون محايد
خليني بقول لك فلسفة
نرجع لموضوع الحياد والموضوعية
فيه جدل تاريخي حول الموضوعية
عند أهل الإعلام وأهل البحث
البحوث الإجرائية أو البحوث الإجتماعية
البحوث بشتى أنواعها حتى البحوث الأكاديمية
فيه دائمًا خلاف بينهم على موضوع الموضوعية
ما بين الحقيقة وما بين النموذج التخيلي الجميل
فيه كثير منهم يقولون لك: الموضوعية يجب أن تكون موجودة
وفيه ناس يقولون لك: هذا موضوع
هذه قضية تخيلية لا يمكن أن تكون بأي حال من الأحوال موجودة
وصلوا إلى منطقة وسطى في مرحلة تاريخية
المنطقة الوسطى قالوا
بأن العلوم الإنسانية احنا لا نشترط فيها المهنية، ليش؟
قالوا: لأن الإنسان هو مجموعة من المشاعر
والتراكمات المعرفية والخبرية والحياتية
ما يمكن أن تفصله عنها
كلام صحيح
جاوا الباقيين قالوا: إذن هو مو صحفي فيه
قالوا: لنتفق في منطقة وسطى
الجوانب الإنسانية ما يطالب فيها المهنية
جاء فريق آخر قال: خلونا نكبّر الصورة
مين يؤسس الإعلام؟
قالوا: شركات وحكومات
قالوا: هل يؤسسون لهدف نبيل دائمًا؟ أو لأهدافهم الخاصة؟
فانقسمت الأراء. ما في أحد قال هدف نبيل
بس انقسمت ما بين أهداف خاصة وأهداف سياسية
و أهداف اجتماعية واقتصادية
قال: اللي دفع فلوس في كل هذه الأشياء
من أجل أن يقاتل على الموضوعية!
إذن الفكرة من أساسها نسفت، فكرة الموضوعية صح؟
صح
إذا وصلنا إلى هذه المرحلة اللي اتفقنا عليها
نسفت تمامًا ما أصبحت موجودة
لكن فيه فريق ما يزال يقول لك
الفريق اللي يتمسك بأشياء أنا في رأيي أنها اندثرت
الموضوعية في جوانب موضوعية
الموضوعية في الجوانب البحثية موجودة
الموضوعية في جوانب الصحافة إلى حدٍ ما موجودة
دخل مصطلح عدم الانحياز ودخل مصطلح الحيادية
ودخلت مصطلحات اللي شوي تمازجت المفاهيم فيها
فأصبحت الصورة ماهي بواضحة ما بين الموضوعية والحيادية
وهل الموضوعية منهج صحفي أو منهج بحثي
مقبول في البحث وغير مقبول في الصحافة؟
وهل الحيادية موقف أو منهج؟
طبعًا جاوا وتكلم عن...
في الأبحاث قيل بأن لا يجب أن تكون موضوعيًّا في بعض القضايا
تخيل لا يجب أن تكون موضوعيًّا في بعض القضايا
وصلت إلى مرحلة أنه في سنة 1996
نقابة الصحافة الأمريكية أسقطت مصطلح الموضوعية
من أدبياتها الصحفية
أُسقطت تمامًا
متى؟
عشان أسند أنا، لأننا قاعدين نتكلم في شيء
يمكن الناس تنقله كمعلومات كاملة
طبعًا أنا ما قرأته في أي شيء يتصل بنقابة الصحفيين
قرأته في مقال
بس عشان يكون واضح
وصلنا إلى هذه المرحلة، أيش بقى من الموضوعية؟
ولا شيء
أيش بقى منها؟
الموضوعية البحثية
موجودة الموضوعية البحثية هي ضد الذاتية
الموضوعية في النقاش هي ضد الذاتية
أنا لما أجي أقول يا عبدالرحمن أنا وياك قاعدين نناقش فكرة
بس أنت قاعد تقول: يا أخي أيش أنت؟
أصلًا بالله هذا شكل برنامج وأنت طالع مسوي كذا؟
رحت الذاتية أنا وتركت الموضوعية
هذه موجودة
دائمًا أقول لك مثل ما قلنا في بداية حديثنا
الاختلاف وتداخل المفاهيم في الإعلام كبير جدًّا
تخيل أن في الجوانب البحثية
بعض الناس اشترط في أمور البحث أو بعض المتخصصين
أنك يجب أن تتخلى عن كثير من المسلّمات
وتدخل مع نفس الفريق اللي انت تبحث عنه
كما أنت واحد منهم، عشان تتخلى عن الذاتية
أقول لك مثال بعد الحلقة على هذا الموضوع
أجل ننهي الحلقة عشان تقول لي إياه
لا، هذا شيء مر علي في موضوع البحث الاجتماعي
واحد كان يبحث عن فئة من الناس
فضطر أنه يشاركهم نفس التفاصيل عشان يكون موضوعي
تحديات والله، الله يعطيك العافية
مليت مني؟
مليت خلاص، تعبت
أفا! أنا والله شوف في حياتي سويت لقائين
وأنا استمتعت معك
الله يسعدك
شكرًا لكم، شكرًا لمشاري الحمود في إعداد الحلقة
ووهاب موسى خلف الكاميرات
عبدالعزيز المزي في تسجيل الصوت
محمد الحسن في الهندسة الصوتية
ومحمد نور شمّت في التحرير
وعبدالمجيد العطاس في التلوين
وفي إدارة محتوى التواصل الاجتماعي نورة السبيعي
ومنتج البرنامج أيمن الحمّادي
وإدارة التحرير أسيل با عبدالله
هذا فنجان أحد منتجات شركة ثمانية للنشر والتوزيع
ننشر كل الإنتاج بحب من مدينة الرياض
الأسبوع المقبل؛ ألقاكم
أنا عندي سؤال بالمعنى كذا
عشان باخذ منكم خبرة أنتم
الفن الوحيد اللي ما سويته أنا البودكاست
فأبغى أسوي بودكاست
لازم أجي كذا بدون شماغ في البودكاست؟
وللا ما يطلع بودكاست؟
لازم وللا ما يطلع بودكاست
ليش؟ أيش السبب؟
لا، أمزح
كلهم كذا!
لا، ما عليك أنا أقول لك شيء ...
أو اللي يجي لابس كاب
أنا بقول لك أيش السبب
أو يجي مفسّر يديه كذا ومشمّر
وشعره مو مرتب
لازم نسوي كذا عشان البودكاست؟
هل لازم ألبس كرفتة وللا مقدر أطلع على «العربية»
هذا أسلوب جريء لقناة
أيش دعوة، بطلع بشماغي وعقالي!
لا، أسلوب قناة
طيب، فالقصد هو أسلوب أنت تختاره
فاحنا اسلوب اخترناه
عبدالرحمن سؤال
أنا بقول لك، بجاوبك
أنت سألت خلني أجاوب
لا، بس على موضوع القناة
أنت تروح للعشاء مثل ما تروح للإستراحة؟
لا
عشاء رسمي؟
طيب؟
ممتاز، احنا نقول نعتقد والله أعلم
الهدف هنا، الشماغ إذا لبسته
فيها رسمية
وأنك تقدر تقدم مادة أفضل وتقرب للناس
إذا حسينا أن احنا متكّين في استراحة وجالسين نسولف
أو في مقهى
هذا الهدف اللي احنا سويناه
أنا مالي علاقة أيش الناس برّا ثمانية تسوي
كلهم صاروا كذا
يمكن أنتم أصبحتم قادة للمرحلة؟
ممكن، وممكن أن هذا ديدن في العالم
أنت تقدم مادة تشبه الناس، أقرب للناس
نحن شعارنا نقول: أننا صحافة تشبه الناس
ممكن ألبس شماغ وأنا أقدّم بودكاست ما يمنع
أبد، تقدر تسوي اللي تبي
لأن هذه الأشياء اللي لفتت انتباهي في البودكاست
كلهم صاروا كذا
فأنا قاعد أقول...
أنا أفهمك ترى قبل شوي يوم تقول
نوع من الرسالة تسهيل الحوار وتبسيطه
حتى على الضيف
أنا ودي أن الضيف يأخذ راحته
أنا ترى مبسوط أصلًا
بس فهذا الهدف والله
قلت لك من البداية مبسوط
مع أني أحسك جاي وأنت دفاعي بشكل
لا، لا
والله يعني...
أنا ترى رجل حماسي فأسلوبي كذا في الحوار
وأنت يمكنك بس حضّرت حق سنة 2008
بس هو ثمانية، أي شيء له علاقة بثمانية أنا أحضر له
غير ثمانية ما...
هو رقم مميز
رقم مميز، متأكد
لا، رقم مميز جدًّا
حتى في النحو والصرف رقم ثمانية مميز
ليه؟
أنت عارف قاعدة النحو حقت ثمانية وللا؟
لا والله
«واو الثمانية»
طبعًا التعداد في اللغة العربية
مثلًا: «مُسْلِمَاتٍ مُّؤْمِنَاتٍ قَانِتَاتٍ تَائِبَاتٍ عَابِدَاتٍ سَائِحَاتٍ ثَيِّبَاتٍ وَأَبْكَارًا»
في الثمانية، سميت «واو الثمانية»
تجي في الثامنة
«وَيَقُولُونَ سَبْعَةٌ وَثَامِنُهُمْ كَلْبُهُمْ»
بس اللي قبل «سَيَقُولُونَ ثَلاثَةٌ رَابِعُهُمْ كَلْبُهُمْ وَيَقُولُونَ خَمْسَةٌ سَادِسُهُمْ كَلْبُهُمْ»
فسميت «واو الثمانية»
أغرب شيء في الموضوع
هذا طبعًا مش تسجيل الآن
عشان ما أبغى أخبّص بالقرآن
طبعًا وأنت داخل الغرفة هذه...
طبعا ثمانية مهمة، على رقم ثمانية
ثمانية كان يلبسها «فهد العريفي»
واحد من أعظم لعيبة الوسط
«التيماوي»
و«التيماوي» واحد من أعظم الأصدقاء والرجال، غير الملعب
والله وستين نِعم
والله ونِعم فيهم كلهم
ثمانية رقم رائع
الشاهد أيش هو؟
أيش كنت أقول لك، أيش جاب ثمانية؟
أيوة تبغى تسوي بودكاست
هي ودي أنك تسوي شيء مختلف والله
هل لو أعطيتك كل شيء أنت تبغاه
أيش شكل الصحيفة اللي أنت تبغى تسويها؟
أعطيك موارد لا محدودة
اللي أنت تبيه؛ ابدأ من الصفر، أيش بتسوي؟
أنا أقول أن الرياضة الآن هي المكان الوحيد
اللي تقدر تفتح فيه قنوات، هي والسياسة
بقيت الأشياء فاشلة في الوقت الحالي
افتح منصات لا تفتح قنوات
منصات
بس شوف «إس إس سي» أيش رأيك في تجربتهم؟
«إس إس سي»؟
قناة رياضية
أيش رأيك في تجربتهم؟
هذا تسجل وللا مو تسجل؟
تسجيل
والله شوف
إذا طلعت برّا الغرفة
لا، بقول لك رأيي بكل صراحة
أنا أزعم أن وحدة من مشاكلي صراحتي، أزعم
«إس إس سي» بداية كانت مش واضحة
هم أصلًا أيش يبغون؟ مش واضحة
بدوا يعودون إلى تقييم أنفسهم
ومحاولة إيجاد الطريق اللي هو بيوصلهم للأهداف من جديد
هل هي مقنعة جدًّا؟
أنا بالنسبة لي حتى الآن غير مقنعة لكنها في الطريق
عندها صراحة كفاءات جيدة مش واو
عندهم كفاءات جيدة
معليش زملائي ما يزعلون، يأخذونها من أخوهم الكبير
ولكنهم يحتاجون إلى أكثر
لو نقل الدوري «بي إن سبورت» بيكون أحسن؟
«بي إن»؟
أنا مو معجب بتجربة «بي إن»
والله؟
إيه، ماني معجب بالقدرات اللي فيها بصراحة
لكن الإمكانيات الضخمة
لا جدال أنها توفرت على أعظم إمكانيات توفرت لقناة تلفزيونية
مش بس رياضية
شوف كم المراسلين الهائلين اللي موجودين
شوف كم من الاستوديوهات الهائلة اللي موجودة
شوف كم الضيوف
ترى ضيوف الرياضة، أكثر الضيوف تدفع لهم
والله؟
أكثر من أي مكان آخر
ترى السياسة ما تدفع لهم فلوس
يعني أنت بتستضيف وزير، بيقول لك كم تدفع؟
أكيد ما راح يقول لك
تستضيف وزير سابق بيقول لك كم تدفع وأعطيك؟
الرياضة كلهم يقولون
على طول؟
طبعًا، يقول لك: خلاص بيكلمك مدير أعمالي
وتتعاقد معه بالشيء الفلاني
واوا!
احنا كنا نفاوض قبل فترة واحد إنقليزي مع تغيرات الدوري
فنجم من نجوم الكرة الإنقليزية
«بيكهام»؟
لا، مش «بيكهام»
قال: أبغى 40 ألف دولار شهري
يطلع كم
العشرة بأربعين مثلًا أحسبها
قلت له: يا كابتن احنا قناة أخبار، مش قناة رياضية
قال لي: أنا رايح قناة أخبار في تركيا
بيستضيفوني على الدوري التركي دافعين لي أربعين
بتدفعون أكثر وللا لا؟
فالرياضة ترى مصاريفها هائلة
الحقوق في الرياضة يا عبدالرحمن
كم تشتري الحقوق؟
«الملخصات» بكم تشتريها؟
التجربة عندكم في قناة «الشرق»؟
عندكم مو بعندنا، طبعًا أنا وأنت ما بننتهي
أيوة شوفي قناة «الشرق» كم اشترت «الملخصات»؟
برضه بالشيء الفلاني
بس ملخصات
بس المشكلة يا أخي والله أنه يزعّل لما أتفرج دور الدوري السعودي
ليش؟
الجودة
أنا والله ما أتفرج الاستديوهات التحليلية كثير
فيه بعض المبارايات ينقلونها «4 كيه»
بس حتى تلقاه، ما أدري
فيه تخبيص
قصدك أنت في حركة الكاميرا والإخراج؟
حركة الكاميرا، حتى معدل التحديث حق العدسة
أشياء ما أدري والله...
فتلقى الكرة تنطط
واضح أنها سُددت بسرعة
أشياء تقهر، بس إن شاء الله أنهم...
إن شاء الله أنهم يتطورون
يارب
الشباب تجاربهم اللي موجودين جيدة
إن شاء الله يكونون أفضل في المستقبل
أنا من النوع ما أشوف الاستيديوهات
ولا التغطيات اللي قبل ولا بعد، بحكم الشغل
بس هي التسعين دقيقة أشوفها مرضية إلى حدٍ ما
مرضية مش رائعة
بالنسبة لي مرضية، وأشوف التسعين دقيقة بس
والله يوفقهم
عطهم أفكار جديدة أنت، قدّم لهم مشروع، قدم لهم شيء
أنا ما أفهم في الرياضة ولا أتابع الرياضة
فأنت اللي تتابع الرياضة قدّم
وأخوهم الكبير بعد
من برجك العاجي انزل
لا، حرام عليك
ليش تقعد يا عبدالرحمن تتابع «الهلال» بس
وتقول لي قبل شوي ما أتابع؟
الحين ترجع تقول ما أتابع
أيش أسوي؟ لأنك أنت تبغاني ما أتابع
لا، والله
شوفت مباريات المنتخب؟
كوريا وكوستريكا وللا أيش قصدك؟
أيوة
لا، ما شفتها
ما تابعتها؟
لا، ما تابعتها
جد أيش علاقتك في الرياضة؟
علاقة طيبة
تصل لحد 10/5؟
لا، تصل إلى إذا قطعت يدي تلقاها دم أزرق
الله!
لا، جيت من الآخر أنت
لا، بس أتابع مباراة «الهلال» فقط
والمباريات المهمة
بس؟
شفت أمس «الأهلي»
المباراة اللي كذا...
مع أنك مفروض أهلاوي أنت
لا، ما أحس، ما يجي
شوف يولد الإنسان على الفطرة هلالي، بعدين...
أنتوا أهل الجنوب كلكم أهلاوية
لا والله ما أدري
أبوي يشجع «الهلال»
أبوك يشجع «الهلال»؟
إيه، بس لسبب غريب ترى
أيش؟
عايش في الرياض هو؟
لا أبدا
عايش في الجنوب؟
هو شجعه من هو في الجنوب
بس لسبب غريب
أيش؟
أنه وُلد في نفس السنة اللي تأسس فيها نادي «الهلال»
الله!
فأعجبه وشجع «الهلال»
لا، بس هذا ارتباط غريب
ليش؟
أنه يشجع «الهلال» عشان نفس السنة
مدري والله، بس الحمد لله فكل العائلة هلالية عن بكرة أبيها
احنا بيتنا متنوع
مشكلة التنوع
فيه نصراويين، وفيه اتحاديين، تخيل!
شوف اتحادي ما عندي مشكلة
بس ما عندنا أهلاويين
الهلاليين اتحاديين
أخوي نواف وعى في فترة «الاتحاد» الذهبي
و«محمد نور» و«توكار» و«كريري»
والعالم المجانين دولي اللي أخذوا آسيا مرتين وكذا
شبّ على... و«الاتحاد» كان فريق
مبدع أيام «موسى البلوي»؟
لا،كان فريق عظيم
على طاري «موسى البلوي»
أي رؤساء الأندية تشوفه الأفضل من اللي عاصرتهم؟
طبعًا أنا عاصرت ناس في فترة وأنا صغير
يوم كنت في الجامعة واشتغل الصحافة
ما كان عندي الوعي الكافي للحكم صراحة
أظلم ناس، مثلًا أنا لحقت على سنوات بسيطة
من «عبدالرحمن بو سعود» بس كنت لا شيء
هامشي في الصحافة
أصلًا توني أتعلم، ما عندي الوعي الكامل
أيش رأيك في اللي قاله عليك؟
قال عني أشياء كثيرة
وسويت معه لقاء قبل ما يموت الله يرحمه لقاء صحفي
قال مرة عني بطّال، رحمة الله عليه الله يسامحه يارب ويغفر له
من أحسن الناس في الرياضة
ما شفنا منه إلا كل خير
بس نقول الله يسامحه من باب أنه من الأموات
والله يا عبدالرحمن، فيه نقطة مهمة
لازم تنتبه لها وأن تنظر لرؤساء الأندية
مثلًا، أقول لك «عبدالله بن مساعد»
مو لأنه صديقي، هم كثير أصدقاء لي في كل الجوانب
«عبدالله بن مساعد» نظّم «الهلال» من الداخل
بشكل ليس له مثيل في الأندية السعودية
هيكلة وشغل وإلى آخره، بس ما حقق بطولات
في رئاسته الأولى؟
«عبدالله بن مساعد» ما حقق إلا بطولة وحدة، تخيل كأس
دوري ما جاب
فلذلك التصنيف هنا يقول لك
أن عبدالله ما نجح مقارنة برؤساء «الهلال» الثانيين
لكن هو من الداخل اشتغل شغل
هذا الشغل اللي من الداخل ما أحد يدري عنه
ترى ما أحد ينتبه له، ما أحد أصلًا يتكلم عنه
يمكن كثير من رؤساء الأندية نفس الشيء
سووا هيكلة داخلية، سووا تنظيم مالي، سووا حوكمة
قبل كل هذه الأشياء، ما تكون اشتراطات
سووا أشياء مستقبلية بعيدة المدى
بس هذه ما ننظر لها، ما تُنظر في التقييم الجماهيري
على مستوى الفكر واللعب والخبث والذكاء
أنا أعتقد أن «نواف بن سعد» كان خطير
وعلى مستوى حتى الوفاء عند الكلمة وأشياء كثيرة
من أحسن ناس اللي تعاملت معهم أنا
صراحة ذكي جدًّا جدًّا في تعامله مع الإعلام
وذكي جدًّا جدًّا في إدارة ناديه
ولا يفتقد للمكر، ولا يفتقد للخبث
ولا يفتقد للعب على المراحل
ممتاز جدًّا جدًّا فيها هذه
واحد من أحسن الناس اللي تعاملت معاهم
أو من أفضل الرؤوساء اللي أنا تعاملت معهم
عندك أيضًا «عبدالله بن مساعد» ما كان سهل
بس مر بمنعطفات صعبة كثير
«النصر» ما تقدر تقول أن أحد يصبر أصلًا
النصراويين قومٌ يتنازعون على أي شيء
فهم النصراويين تلقاهم مثلًا يقيّمون للرئيس تقييمات غير عادلة
فيه ناس يقولون دائمًا
«الهلال» الرئيس يجي يكمل ما قبله
«النصر» يجي ينسف ما قبله
أساسًا النصراوي اللي جاء ما لقى قبله شيء
هذه حقيقة، ما لقى شيء عملي منهجي عشان يكمله
كله إجتهادات فردية
ويجي يقول: وحدة من سمات «الهلال» الاستمرارية
لأنه يكمل ما قبله
«النصر» ما لقى شيء
هو كذا لا طلع لقى النادي كذا
لقى رئيس ناديه
إيه، لقى الأمور كذا، فمضطر أنه يبدأ من جديد
«البلطان» كيف علاقتك معه؟
«البلطان» أنا وياه الأصدقاء الألداء
نحترم بعضنا ونصل لمرحة الصداقة لحدٍ ما خارج الكرة
وداخل الكرة نلعب أنا وياه مع بعض
نلعب واحد اثنين، وأحيانًا نتحايل على بعض
بس هو رجل ذكي في اللوائح تحديدًا
ذكي جدًّا، ماكر من الدرجة الأولى
و«البلطان» جني، عفريت بمعنى الكلمة
والصراحة يا أخي عبدالرحمن
واحد ناديه يقع بين أنياب «الهلال» و«النصر»
ويظهر للضوء
يقول لك الناس: أنه ارتمى في أحضان «الهلال»
ووجد الدفء وما أدري أيش
هو عاند «الهلال» هو الفترة الأخيرة
هذه إلى حدٍ ما صحيحة
بس هو برضه مو سهل أبدًا
والصراحة يوم تشوف «الشباب»
قبل ما يرجع «البلطان» رجعته الأخيرة وما بعده
تقول يا «البلطان» شكرًا جزيلًا
النادي كان واقف بوجودك
بس قبلك النادي كان ضايع ضياع مو بطبيعي
والحين ضايع
بس هو رجل تحدي، يجيبها من يمين ويجيبها من يسار
المهم توقف الدنيا، كيف؟ ما يهم
وشرس جدًّا
طيب الحين «بن نافل» و«بن مسلي» و«الحايلي» أيهم؟
حول بعض كلهم
حول بعض؟
شوف رياضيًّا وإدارة رياضية «المسلّي» أقربهم، ليش؟
لأنه يشتغل في الرابطة وابن الرياضة وإلى آخره
«أنمار» أنا والله ما أعرفه عن قرب
علاقتنا بسيطة مش ذيك العلاقة القوية
ماهي بسيئة ولا جيدة
بس ما أعرفه عن قرب عشان أحكم عليه
«فهد» أعرفه إلى حدٍ ما
«فهد» عنده ميزة ممتازة
اختيار الفريق ممتاز عنده
الإيمان بالتخصص ممتاز عنده
قاعد يسويها في إدارته، وهذا شيء من الإدارة الممتازة
وفوق هذا عنده فريق ممتاز
«فهد» دعوة مباركة جابته في ذا الفترة
ما جاء في فترة ثانية، كيف؟
العمل اللي قدمه «نواف بن سعد» طول تاريخه
وجزء بسيط عشان ما نظلمه بعد
«سامي» في ثلاثة شهور سوّى تعاقدات هائلة لـ«الهلال» لا شك
في الثلاثة شهور اللي هو قعدها رئيس
«فهد» جاء لقى كل شيء تمام عنده
سوّى لمسات بسيطة
كان يتوافر على أفضل جيل في تاريخ «الهلال»
تبي تجي تقول الجيل ما فيه «الثنيان»
صحيح ما فيه «الثنيان»
بس ما فيه أحد حقق كأس آسيا مرتين مثل كذا وراء بعض
تقول الجيل ما فيه «سامي الجابر»
بس ما فيه أحد حقق الدوري ثلاث مرات
أول مرة ترى «الهلال» يحقق الدوري ثلاث مرات متتالية في تاريخه
بس دوري المحترفين عنده سبع ألقاب
أظن سبع ألقاب إذا ماني بناسي
أنت هلالي علمنا كم؟
لا أبد، أنت الصحفي، أنا مو صحفي
معلومة، المسلم لا يجب أن يكون حافظًا للقرآن
صح؟
صحيح
يجوز أن تكون مسلم وتدخل الجنة وأنت منت بحافظ القرآن
أنا بدخل الجنة دام أني خلصت هذا اللقاء، وأنا لسه فيني...
ليش؟
لهذه الدرجة أنا سيء؟
يلا أنا بمشي
نشفت ريقي